Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the rest is history.com and join the club. That is the rest is history.com. This episode is brought to you by Hive. You know, history is full of transformations. The Romans shifted from Republic to Empire. the Tudor's transformed monasteries into country houses. And do you know what? Hive has had one of its own. Everybody knows Hive for smart thermostats, but now they've evolved into something much greater. Solar panels that help you to power your home with clean energy. Heat pumps that pull warmth from thin air.
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）。想要获取每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听、系列节目的抢先体验，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问therestisistory.com并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestisistory.com。本集由 Hive 赞助播出。你知道，历史充满了变革。罗马人从共和国转变为帝国，都铎王朝将修道院改造成了乡间别墅。你知道吗？Hive 也经历了属于它自己的变革。大家都知道 Hive 的智能温控器，但现在它们已经发展成为更伟大的存在。太阳能电池板帮助你用清洁能源为家庭供电，热泵从稀薄空气中提取热量。
EV charges that charge your car while you're asleep. All managed through a single app. This is all about giving people the power to transform their homes, from waste to efficiency, from dependence to control, from consumption to contribution. So history's next great transformation may not be happening in parliaments or palaces. It may be happening in your home. A quiet revolution minus guillotine's. Hive. Know your power. Visit hivehome.com to find out more. Subject to survey and suitability, Hive app compatible with selected heat pumps. This episode is brought to you by SAP. With investors, customers, and workers demanding more from your business, it's time to try SAP. Its AI-powered capabilities can help you streamline costs, connect with new suppliers and manage payroll even when your business is being pulled in different directions, to deliver a quality product
还有在你入睡时为汽车充电的电动汽车充电器。这一切都通过一个应用程序进行管理。这关乎于赋予人们改造家园的力量，从减少浪费到提高效率，从产生依赖到获得控制，从消耗资源到贡献力量。因此，历史上下一个伟大的变革或许不会发生在议会或宫殿里，而是可能发生在你的家里。一场没有断头台的无声革命。Hive，了解你的力量。访问 hivehome.com 了解更多信息。视实地勘测和适用情况而定，Hive 应用程序兼容部分热泵。本集由 SAP 赞助播出。随着投资者、客户和员工对您的企业提出更高要求，是时候尝试 SAP 了。它由人工智能驱动的功能可以帮助您精简成本、连接新供应商并管理薪资，即使您的企业正被拉向不同的方向，也能交付优质产品
at a fair price, while paying your people what they're worth too, so your business can stay unfazed. more at SAP.com slash uncertainty. The news spread quickly. Across the British fleet, the lookouts were pointing and crying out, and men were pounding up the ladders and pouring from the hatchways, cheering and shouting for all they were worth. There, 11 miles to the east, was the complete.
以公平的价格，同时给予员工应得的薪酬，让您的企业在面对不确定性时依然气定神闲。更多信息请访问 SAP.com 斜杠 uncertainty。消息迅速传开。在整个英国舰队中，瞭望员们指指点点、大声呼喊，水兵们冲上梯子，从舱口涌出，发出他们所能表达的最高热情的欢呼和呐喊。就在那里，东边十一英里处，是完整的。
bind fleet. A jaw-dropping spectacle spread out across the horizon in the glow of the dawn. On the quarter-deck of the victory, a cloud seemed to pass from Horatio Nelson's face. He had barely slept, but he felt free of care. This was his moment. Every ship he had ever taken, Every voyage he had ever made had led to this hour. The victory spread her sails. Then Nelson ordered his signal lieutenant to hoist two messages. First came the order to form two divisions as planned. And then came the signal they had all been waiting for.
联合舰队。在黎明的微光中，一幅令人叹为观止的壮观景象在海平线上展开。在“胜利号”的后甲板上，一团阴云似乎从霍雷肖·纳尔逊的脸上消散了。他几乎没怎么睡觉，但他感到一身轻松。这是属于他的时刻。他经历过的每一艘船，他进行过的每一次航行，都通向了这一个小时。“胜利号”张开了风帆。随后，纳尔逊命令他的信号长升起两组旗语。首先是按计划组成两个纵队的命令。接着是他们一直在等待的信号。
Prepare for battle. So begins the climactic chapter. of Adventures in Time, Nelson, Hero of the Seas, which Dominic, I'm sure you'd agree, must surely rank as the definitive life of this extraordinary man written, of course, by yourself. And it has been a very long voyage, has it not, from Burnham Thorpe, where we set out 11 episodes ago. But now we are reaching the glorious and tragic conclusion of this story. So would you like to set the scene for the listeners? I would, Tom. The date is the 21st of October, 1805, a Monday. It's 5 o'clock in the morning,
准备战斗。这就是扣人心弦的章节的开始。——来自《时间历险记：海洋英雄纳尔逊》（Adventures in Time, Nelson, Hero of the Seas）。多米尼克，我想你一定会同意，这绝对堪称这部非凡人物的权威生平传记，当然是由你本人撰写的。从我们十一集前出发的伯纳姆索普（Burnham Thorpe）到这里，这是一段非常漫长的航程，不是吗？但现在我们正迎来这个故事光荣而又悲壮的结局。那么，你想为听众们搭建一下场景吗？我愿意，汤姆。日期是1805年10月21日，星期一。现在是早上5点，
and off the southwestern coast of Spain, Nelson's fleet have finally caught up with their quarry, their combined fleet of France and Spain under Pierre Charles de Villeneuve and Federico Gravina. And listeners who have been on this journey all the way from Burnham-Thorpe will remember what is at stake. So for months, Nelson has been planning a war of annihilation. He intends to exploit the speed and firepower of the Royal Navy to sail right at the combined fleet in two assault columns, one led by his own ship, the victory, and the other by his deputy Admiral Collingwood in the Royal Sovereign. And his goal is to smash the enemy line into pieces and then to mop them up one by one. If he wins, Britain's command of the seas, Britain's naval mastery will be
在西班牙西南海岸外，纳尔逊的舰队终于追上了他们的猎物——由皮埃尔·查尔斯·德·维尔讷夫（Pierre Charles de Villeneuve）和费德里科·格拉维纳（Federico Gravina）率领的法西联合舰队。一路从伯纳姆索普跟随这段旅程的听众会记得，此时此刻的关键所在。几个月来，纳尔逊一直在策划一场歼灭战。他打算利用皇家海军的速度和火力，分两路进攻纵队直扑联合舰队，一路由于他自己的旗舰“胜利号”率领，另一路则由他的副手柯林伍德（Collingwood）海军中将率领的“皇家主权号”率领。他的目标是将敌人的战线砸得粉碎，然后将其各个击破。如果他赢了，英国对海洋的控制权、英国的海军霸权将
confirmed for a generation. Britain will be definitively secure from invasion, and they can pursue a naval blockade strategy that will eventually bring Napoleon to his knees. But if he loses, then the combined fleet could regain control of the Mediterranean or could turn north, France and Spain could conceivably win control of the channel, and Napoleon's plans to invade Britain could be back on. So massive, massive stakes. And of course, Dominic, the stakes are personally very high for Nelson as well.
得以确立整整一代人的时间。英国将彻底免受入侵的威胁，他们可以推行海军封锁战略，最终让拿破仑屈服。但如果他输了，那么联合舰队可能会重新夺回对地中海的控制权，或者转向北方，法西两国完全有可能夺得英吉利海峡的控制权，拿破仑入侵英国的计划可能会死灰复燃。因此，赌注极其、极其重大。当然，多米尼克，对于纳尔逊个人而言，赌注也非常高。
And it's so important to emphasize this because he is leading one of those two prongs of the attack in victory. And ages ago, when we previously did a series on Trafalgar, we called him a Christian Achilles. He's a man of deep Christian faith. but he does also have this kind of homeric quality, doesn't he? And I think there is something of Achilles in his determination to risk death because it will provide him with the opportunity for incredible glory, which isn't to say that he wants to die. He does not want to die.
强调这一点非常重要，因为他正率领“胜利号”参与其中一个进攻分队。很久以前，当我们之前制作特拉法尔加海战系列节目时，我们称他为“基督教的阿喀琉斯”。他是一个有着坚定基督教信仰的人。但他确实也带有一种荷马史诗般的特质，对吧？我认为在他甘冒死亡风险的决心中有某种阿喀琉斯式的影子，因为这会为他提供获得无上荣耀的机会，这并不是说他想死。他并不想死。
We know from his letters to Emma that he was preparing, you know, if they win Trafalgar, he will lay down his command. He will live with Emma. They'll have children, all of that. But, like Achilles, he would rather die a hero than duck his chance for glory. And so this is why in the previous episode we described him preparing his coffin. And his journal on leaving England, he wrote, If it is God's good providence to cut short my days upon earth,
从他写给埃玛的信中我们知道，他一直在做准备，你知道的，如果他们在特拉法尔加获胜，他就会卸下指挥权。他会和埃玛生活在一起。他们会有孩子，诸如此类。但是，就像阿喀琉斯一样，他宁愿像英雄一样死去，也不愿逃避获取荣耀的机会。所以这就是为什么在上一集中，我们描述了他在准备自己的棺材。他在离开英格兰时的日记中写道：如果承蒙上帝的善意，要缩短我在世间的日子，
I bow with the greatest submission, relying that he will protect those so dear to me that I leave behind. And you could imagine had Achilles being Christian, that's how he might have put it. Yeah, there's a fatalism to Nelson, isn't there? which is obviously born of his years of experience in the Navy. He knows just how horrendous naval battles are. I mean, the sort of tempest of splinters and shot and screaming and blood. Well, he's been hit on the head, hasn't he, by a beam? He's had his arm chopped off.
我将以最大的顺从鞠躬，深信他会保护我身后那些对我如此亲爱的人。你可以想象，如果阿喀琉斯是基督徒，他大概也会这么说。是的，纳尔逊身上有一种宿命论，对吧？这显然源于他在海军多年的经验。他深知海战是多么恐怖。我是说，那种到处都是碎片、炮弹、尖叫和鲜血的风暴。你看，他的头部不是曾被横梁击中过吗？他的手臂也被截断过。
You know, all kinds of things have gone on. His eyes gone. Exactly. But the sort of paradox is at the same time that he has this kind of fatalism, which will recur in this episode, there is a sense of absolute confidence in his ships and his men. You know, everything in his life, all the years of training, all the years of service, all the battles.
你知道，各种各样的事情都发生过。他的眼睛也失明了。正是如此。但其中的悖论在于，尽管他有着这种会在本集中再次出现的宿命论，但与此同时，他对自己的舰船和部下有着绝对的信心。你知道的，他生命中的一切，所有的训练岁月，所有的服役岁月，所有的战斗。
Everything has prepared him for this moment. And yes, he is only one man and a brilliant commander, but behind him is an unequalled military machine, the most lethal killing machine in the world. And one that is based on what he stands for at Trafalgar is the economic and industrial might and modernity of industrial Britain. Because of that, he knows that his. men are fitter, quicker, better trained, more adept than their French and Spanish opponents.
一切都为他准备好了迎接这一刻。是的，他只一个人，也是一个杰出的指挥官，但在他身后的是一台无与伦比的军事机器，是世界上最具杀伤力的杀机器。而这台机器所建立的基础——他在特拉法尔加所代表的——是工业化英国的经济、工业实力与现代化。正因如此，他知道他的人民
And indeed, his French and Spanish opponents know it themselves and have frankly and freely said so. So when he gives the command, this machine, you know, it's like terrible cliché, like a clockwork machine kind of springs into action. People are stowing away the hammocks, the last of the furniture. The surgeons are kind of getting out their instruments. If you've seen Master and Command of the film, there's a sort of moment. when they're beating to quarters and everyone rushing into action. Yeah. That's what this is like.
体能更好、反应更快、训练更精良、比他们的法国和西班牙对手更熟练。事实上，他的法国和西班牙对手自己也心知肚明，并且坦率而自由地承认了这一点。因此，当他下达命令时，这台机器，你知道的，就像一个可怕的陈词滥调，像一个发条装置一样开始运转。人们在收起吊床，收拾最后的家具。外科医生们正在摆出他们的器械。如果你看过电影《怒海争锋》（Master and Commander），就会有那种他们敲响战斗警报、每个人都冲向战斗岗位的时刻。对。这就是这种感觉。
And there's kind of dread, isn't there? Because they know what it is to be in a battle. But also the excitement of people who have been kind of training all their lives for this moment. I mean, you can imagine the atmosphere is one of mingled. There must be a little bit of fear and dread, but also tremendous anticipation finally after all these months, after years of waiting. And confidence, I would guess. Yes, exactly. So let's go through the timeline. At 7.30 in the morning, Nelson signals to his frigate captains to come aboard the victory. The frigates are smaller ships, for those people are not massively familiar with the Royal Navy. Unlike us. Yes, we're tremendously familiar with our tremendous knowledge. Yes, exactly. Yeah, undoubtedly, in the Chatham High Street episode, did we not confuse a destroyer and a battleship? Is that not the great sin that we committed? A few listeners noted that. deliberate mistake and good on them. I like to keep them on their toes.
并且有一种恐惧感，对吧？因为他们知道身处战场是什么滋味。但同时也有一种兴奋感，那是那些为这一刻训练了一生的人所特有的兴奋。我的意思是，你可以想象那里的气氛是交织着各种情绪的。肯定有一点恐惧和害怕，但经历了这么多个月、几年的等待之后，最终迎来了巨大的期待。还有信心，我猜是的。是的，完全如此。那么，让我们来过一遍时间线。早上7点30分，纳尔逊发信号给他的护卫舰舰长们，让他们登上“胜利号”。对于那些对皇家海军不太熟悉的人来说，护卫舰是较小的船只。与我们不同。是的，我们凭借我们丰富的知识，对此极其熟悉。是的，完全如此。是的，毫无疑问，在查塔姆高街（Chatham High Street）那一集里，我们难道没有把驱逐舰和战列舰搞混吗？难道那不是我们犯下的滔天大罪吗？一些听众注意到了那个故意犯下的错误，他们做得好。我喜欢让他们保持警惕。
We were just trying to make it accessible, weren't we? I think that was what we were trying to do. For the non-naval people. Exactly. So anyway, Nelson signals to his frigate captains to come aboard a victory. He is going to need them to signal his orders. The chief frigate commander whom we met in the previous episode bringing the news of Villeneuve's movements to Nelson at Merton is a guy called Henry Blackwood. And Henry Blackwood says to Nelson, why don't you come across to my frigate and command the fleet from there. Why risk your life at the head of the line? Why not be at a safe distance, like a kind of First World War commander, and direct the fleet from there? And a lot of commanders did do this kind of thing. Not all did, but it was not
我们只是想让它变得通俗易懂，不是吗？我想这正是我们当时想做的。为了那些不太了解海军的人。完全如此。所以无论如何，纳尔逊发信号让他的护卫舰舰长登上“胜利号”。他需要他们来传递他的命令。我们在上一集遇到的、将维尔讷夫动向的消息带给默顿（Merton）纳尔逊的主要护卫舰指挥官，是一个叫亨利·布莱克伍德（Henry Blackwood）的人。亨利·布莱克伍德对纳尔逊说：“你为什么不登上我的护卫舰，从那里指挥舰队呢？为什么要冒着生命危险冲在战线的最前端呢？为什么不保持一个安全的距离，像第一次世界大战的指挥官那样，从那里指挥舰队呢？”很多指挥官确实会这样做。并非所有人都会这么做，但这也并非完全闻所未闻。纳尔逊说，门都没有。布莱克伍德一定知道纳尔逊会说门都没有。你知道的，纳尔逊必然会从正面让自己身处险境。但这恰恰表明，他们深知纳尔逊的计划有多么危险——在不给自己先开火机会的情况下直扑敌人。但正因为如此危险，纳尔逊才必须要这么做。如果他不亲自带头，他绝不可能要求部下将自己投身于地狱之口。事实上，你知道的，他希望自己清晰可见。他一直都是这么做的。纳尔逊喜欢穿得花哨一点。所以他全副武装地出现在那里。他的夹克上缝满了骑士勋章，肩章闪闪发光，实际上
totally unknown. And Nelson said, no way. And Blackwood must have known Nelson would say no way. You know, Nelson would be bound to put himself in harm's way from the front. But it's a sign of just how dangerous they know Nelson's plan is to sail directly at the enemy without giving yourself the opportunity to fire first. But that's precisely why Nelson has to do it, because it is so dangerous. He cannot possibly ask his men to throw themselves into the jaws of hell without leading them there himself. And in fact, you know, he wants to be visible. This is what has always done. Nelson loves a bit of bling. So he's there in all his paraphernalia. He's got all those kind of the stars of knighthood sewn onto his jacket, epaulets gleaming, and actually
他船上的一些水手说：“好吧，很高兴您能来，但您为什么不穿一件稍微不那么显眼的衣服呢？”但他不打算这么做。他想吸引所有人的注意力。我猜，这使得纳尔逊个人的风险甚至更高，因为他船上的所有其他军官一样，是不被允许躲避的。水兵可以躲避，但军官不能。无论有多少神枪手，无论有多少霰弹。我的意思是，这简直是疯狂的勇气。对。
some of his men on board the ship say, yeah, I mean, brilliant that you're here, but why don't you just wear a slightly less showy coat? But he's not going to do that. He wants to draw attention to himself. I guess that what makes this even more risky for Nelson personally is that he, like all the other officers on board the ship, are not allowed to duck. The semen can duck, but officers cannot. No matter how many sharpshooters, no matter how many grape shot. I mean, just insane courage. Yeah.
所以他穿着漂亮的衣服，他们出发了。间距是11英里，并且在非常缓慢地缩短，但每一分钟都在缩短。这基本上是步行的速度，对吧？对。因此，联合舰队在海平线上排开。微风习习，所以他们的移动方式非常缓慢、审慎而庄严。伴随着战鼓声，他们穿过波浪。纳尔逊正通过望远镜观察他们。
So he's got his nice coat on, and on they go. The gap is 11 miles and closing very slowly, but it's closing every minute. It's basically walking speed, isn't it? Yeah. So the combined fleet is sort of spread out on the horizon. It's a very faint breeze, so they are moving exactly in a very slow and deliberate and stately way. the kind of the drums beating as they kind of head across the waves. Nelson is surveying them through his telescope.
他可以看到联合舰队基本上是在有些混乱的状态下航行。这不是一个组织得很好的行动。所以他们是一个参差不齐的新月形，从南向北延伸。从前面数大约第12艘船是维尔讷夫的旗舰“布散特号”（Bucentor）。然后在其后面大约六艘船左右是格拉维纳的旗舰“圣安娜号”（Santa Ana），然后还有另外15艘法国或西班牙船只。现在，其中一些船只绝对是庞然大物，正如我们所将讨论的，但纳尔逊充满信心。你知道的，我们有火力和技术来击败他们。
He can see that the combined fleet is basically sailing in slight disorder. It's not a terribly well-organized operation. So they're kind of ragged crescent and they're going from south to north. So about 12 ships from the front is the Villeneuve's flagship, the Bucentor. And then about six ships behind it or so is Gravina's flagship, the Santa. to Anna, and then there's another 15 French or Spanish ships. Now, some of these ships are absolute Leviathans, as we'll discuss, but Nelson is confident. You know, we have the firepower and the skill to beat them.
8点钟，“胜利号”的厨师端上了早餐。少数人紧张得吃不下饭，但大多数人都饿极了。一个水手事后说，他们感觉自己就像渴望大干一场的雄狮，这让你对当时的气氛有所体会。他们喝的是葡萄酒，对吧，而不是格罗格酒（烈酒兑水）？是的，他们喝的是葡萄酒。在战前你会喝一杯葡萄酒吗？我想你会的。是的，我肯定会。
Eight o'clock, the Victories Cook serves breakfast. A few men are too nervous to eat it, but most of them are absolutely ravenous. A sailor said afterwards they felt like lions anxious to be at it, which gives you a sense of the mood. And they're given wine, aren't they, not grog? Yes, they're given wine. Would you have a glass of wine before going to battle? I suppose you would. Yeah, I certainly would.
所以，是的，有一种真正的兴奋感。“埃阿斯号”（Ajax）上的中尉们说，所有人都极其渴望与敌人近距离交战。我们对舰队氛围的大部分了解都来自军官，很显然，因为他们往往更有文化，也写信等。所以你可以感受到整个舰队中，人们跪下来做最后的祷告，或者把纪念品送给朋友，或者写告别信
So, yes, there's a real sense of excitement. So, lieutenants on the Ajax said all seemed deeply anxious to come to close quarters with the enemy. And most of what we know about the mood and the fleet comes from officers, obviously, because they tend to be more literate and they wrote letters and things. So you have a sense of them across the fleet, people kneeling to say their last prayers, or they give keepsakes to their friends, or they write farewell notes. to their families, and often some of these notes, I have to say, are incredibly moving. So there's a young midshipman on the Royal Sovereign, and Colleenwood's flagship called John Aikenhead, who wrote to his mum and dad,
给他们的家人，而且通常其中一些信件，我必须说，极其感人。“皇家主权号”上的一名年轻见习军官，也就是柯林伍德的旗舰上名叫约翰·艾肯黑德（John Aikenhead）的人，写信给他的爸爸妈妈：
should I, my dear parents, fall in defence of my king, let that thought console you. I feel not the least dread on my spirits. Oh, my parents, sisters, brother, day grandfather, grandmother and aunt, believe me ever yours. And here's another story. This is a teenage midshipman called Robert Smith on the victory on Nelson's flagship, who did not survive. the battle. He wrote to what he called his dear and honored parents. He says, I can't wait to face the enemy of my country. And he says, if the worst happens to me, then you, dearest of mothers, consider that your affectionate son could not die in a more glorious cause. And actually, the one
如果我，我亲爱的父母，为了保卫我的国王而牺牲，请让这个想法安慰你们。我的心中没有一丝恐惧。噢，我的父母、姐妹、兄弟、爷爷、奶奶和阿姨，相信我永远是你们的。这里还有另一个故事。这是一个名叫罗伯特·史密斯（Robert Smith）的少年见习军官，他在纳尔逊的旗舰“胜利号”上，没有在战役中幸存下来。他写信给他所谓的亲爱且受人尊敬的父母。他说，我等不及要面对我国家的敌人了。并且他说，如果最坏的情况发生在我身上，那么你，我最亲爱的母亲，请认为你这位充满深情儿子没有死在一个更光荣的事业中。事实上，我
that I always think is really moving is Henry Black with a frigate captain. He wrote to his wife, Adieu, my dearest wife, your Henry will not disgrace his name. And if he dies, his last breath will be devoted to the dearest of dear wives. Take care of my boy. Make him a better man than his father. Yeah, very moving. So, I mean, all of them have loved ones on their mind. And of course, Nelson also has loved ones on his mind. Yes. So he's in his great cabin, isn't he? Which, if you go to Portsmouth, you can obviously see it. It's the highlight of going to the victory. And he must, the furniture has been taken out. So he must have been sitting on the floor, effectively, with his left hand.
一直觉得真正感人的是护卫舰舰长亨利·布莱克伍德。他写信给他的妻子：“再见，我最亲爱的妻子，你的亨利不会辱没他的名字。如果他死了，他的最后一口气也将奉献给我最亲爱的妻子。照顾好我的儿子。把他培养得比他父亲更好。”是的，非常感人。所以，我的意思是，他们所有人的心里都装着挚爱。当然，纳尔逊的心里也装着挚爱。是的。所以他在他的大舱里，对吧？如果你去朴茨茅斯，你显然可以看到它。那是参观“胜利号”的亮点。而且他肯定——家具已经被搬走了。所以他基本上一定是坐在地板上，用他的左手……
Yeah, and as in the Battle of Copenhagen, his portraits of Emma have been taken down, and this time as well he has a portrait of Horatia. And we know they are absolutely uppermost in his thoughts as the victory glides ever so slowly towards the battle line. So he writes one last prayer, doesn't he, Tom? I'm sure you would love to read that. Oh, I would. I mean, this is so moving. May the great God whom I worship grant to my country and for the benefit of Europe in general a great and glorious victory.
是的，就像在哥本哈根战役中一样，他挂着的埃玛的画像被取了下来，这一次他还挂着一张霍拉西亚（Horatia）的画像。我们知道，当“胜利号”极其缓慢地向战线滑行时，她们绝对占据了他心头最重要的位置。所以他写下了最后的祈祷，对吧，汤姆？我确信你很乐意把它读出来。噢，我愿意。我的意思是，这太感人了。愿我所崇拜的伟大的神，赐予我的国家以及整个欧洲的利益一场伟大而光荣的胜利，
and may no misconduct in anyone tarnish it, and may humanity after victory be the predominant feature in the British fleet. For myself individually, I commit my life to him that made me, and may his blessing light upon my endeavours for serving my country faithfully. To him I resign myself and the just cause, which is entrusted to me to defend. Amen, amen, amen. And then, of course, Emma and Horatia. and we talked about this
愿没有任何人的失职玷污它，愿胜利后的人道主义成为英国舰队最显著的特征。就我个人而言，我将我的生命托付给创造了我的那位，愿他的保佑照亮我忠诚服务国家的努力。我将自己和我被委托保卫的正义事业交托于他。阿门，阿门，阿门。然后，当然还有埃玛和霍拉西亚。我们讨论过这个
in the episode we did about four months ago on Emma Hamilton that he writes a codicil to his will I leave Emma Lady Hamilton therefore a legacy to my king and country that they will give her an ample provision
在我们大约四个月前制作的关于埃玛·汉密尔顿（Emma Hamilton）的节目中，他在遗嘱中写下了一个附言：因此，我将埃玛·汉密尔顿夫人作为一份遗赠留给我的国王和国家，希望他们能为她提供丰厚的给养，
to maintain her rank in life I also leave to the beneficence of my country my adopted daughter Horatia Nelson Thompson and I desire she will use in future the name of Nelson only These are the only favours I ask of my king and country at this moment when I am going to fight their battle. And how king and country respond to this request, we will see in next week's bonus when we look at what happened to Emma and Horatia after Trafalgar.
以维持她在生活中的地位。我也将我的养女霍拉西亚·纳尔逊·汤姆逊（Horatia Nelson Thompson）托付给我的国家的仁慈，我希望她将来只使用纳尔逊这个名字。这些是我向我的国王和国家索取的唯一恩惠，在这个我要为他们战斗的时刻。而国王和国家将如何回应这个请求，我们将在下周的加更节目中看到，我们将探讨埃玛和霍拉西亚在特拉法尔加海战之后的遭遇。
So if you're an Emma Hamilton fan like Tom, you will want to be a member of the Restis History Club. And you can, of course, join Tom in that crew at the rest of the rest of the history club. History.com. Or actually, if you're not a fan of M. Hamilton, because in which case you'll enjoy the bonus or the more. Yes, I guess so. So, it's now 10 o'clock in the morning. There are a few miles from their quarry and everything has been prepared.
所以，如果你像汤姆一样是埃玛·汉密尔顿的粉丝，你会想要成为“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的会员。当然，你也可以在therestisistory.com加入汤姆所在的那个圈子。或者其实，如果你不是M·汉密尔顿的粉丝，因为那样的话你会更享受这个加更节目。是的，我想是的。所以，现在是早上10点。距离他们的猎物只有几英里了，一切都准备好了。
The decks have been cleared. They have started watering the timbers to prevent against fire. The red-coated marines have gone to their posts on deck. The gun crews have gone to their stations. They have powder and cartridges and shot. And in his makeshift operating theory, which is called the sort of the surgeon's cockpit down in the bowels of the ship, the ship's Dr. William Beatty has laid out his scalples and his bandages and his bottles of vinegar and all of this kind of thing. And I'm sad to say we will be returning to that particular cockpit later in the episode. He will have been warming his sores, won't he?
甲板已经被清理干净。他们已经开始向木材浇水以防止火灾。穿红军服的海军陆战队员已经就位在甲板上的岗位。炮手们已经到达了他们的战位。他们有火药、弹药和炮弹。在被称为船舱深处外科医生手术室的临时手术台里，舰上的威廉·贝蒂（William Beatty）医生已经摆好了他的手术刀、绷带、醋瓶和诸如此类的一切。我很遗憾地说，我们将在本集稍后回到那个特定的手术室。他会一直在温热他的手术锯，对吧？
Because that was something that Nelson insisted on having had his arm sorn off. Yes, you said it was too cold. And that was the thing that he remembered. So below decks, the gun crews, they would have stripped their waists. They have tied handkerchiefs around their heads and ears to muffle the sound of the guns. They will be, some of them are dancing a jig. The band are playing things like, you know, Royal Britannia, God Save the King, Heart of Oak, all of these kind of patriotic songs to get them in the mood.
因为那是纳尔逊在被锯掉手臂后坚持要有的要求。是的，你说过它太冷了。那是他记忆深刻的事情之一。所以在甲板下方，炮手们脱掉了腰部的衣服。他们在头部和耳朵周围系上手帕，以减弱火炮的声音。他们中的一些人在跳吉格舞（一种欢快的民间舞）。军乐队在演奏诸如《不列颠尼亚万岁》、《天佑吾王》、《橡木之心》之类的爱国歌曲，来调动他们的情绪。
Nelson for the last time tours the ship. He says to his men, he shakes hands with his left hand with his men. He says, do not fire until absolutely sure of your object. In other words, hold your fire until you see the whites of their eyes. And he has never seemed more calm or more confident. My noble lads, he says, this will be a glorious day for England, whoever lives to see it. And on every ship in the fleet, there are similar scenes. The captain's giving these incredibly inspiring speeches to their men saying, you know, we don't back down, we don't surrender.
纳尔逊最后一次巡视战舰。他对部下说，他用左手同部下握手。他说：“在绝对确信你们的目标之前不要开火。”换句话说，“直到看到敌人眼白再开火。”他从未显得如此平静或自信。“我的好小伙子们，”他说，“对英格兰来说，这将是光荣的一天，无论谁活着看到它。”在舰队的每一艘船上，都有类似的场景。舰长们对部下发表这些令人难以置信的鼓舞人心的演讲，说，你知道的，我们不退缩，我们不投降。
I know you will do well. You know, this is going to be a great day. Enjoy it. Get out there and have fun. Exactly. It is like a bit of a sort of football manager before a big game kind of atmosphere. So it's 11 o'clock now.
我知道你们会干得很好的。你知道的，这将是伟大的一天。享受它。走出去，好好玩。正是如此。这有点像重大比赛前夕的足球经理的那种气氛。所以现在是11点。
Nelson takes his place on the quarter deck of the victory. And beside him are the ship's captain, Thomas Hardy, the master of the ship, Thomas Atkinson, the first lieutenant, John Quilliam, and the frigate captain, Henry Blackwood. And they can now see the combined fleet clearly. They can see the decorations on the French and Spanish ships, the gun ports.
纳尔逊在“胜利号”的后甲板上就位。在他身旁的是舰长托马斯·哈迪（Thomas Hardy）、航海长托马斯·阿特金森（Thomas Atkinson）、大副约翰·奎利姆（John Quilliam）以及护卫舰舰长亨利·布莱克伍德。他们现在可以清晰地看到联合舰队了。他们可以看到法国和西班牙船只上的装饰、炮门。
They can see the little figures moving about on deck. And they can see the size of some of their opponents. Yeah, they're monsters, aren't they? Gravina's flagship, the Principia di Asturias, has 112 guns. The Santissima Trinidad, which Nelson had faced at Cape St. Vincent. Is it, I think, a Capes and Vincent? 140 guns. So the biggest ship on Earth.
他们可以看到在甲板上走动的小人影。他们可以看到他们的一些对手的规模。是的，它们是庞然大物，对吧？格拉维纳的旗舰“阿斯图里亚斯亲王号”（Principia di Asturias）拥有112门大炮。“圣地亚哥-特立尼达号”（Santissima Trinidad，纳尔逊在圣文森特角面对过的那艘。我想是在圣文森特角吧？），拥有140门大炮。所以是地球上最大的船。
Four decks. Four decks, an absolute monster. So in total, Villeneuve and Gravina have 33 ships. They have 2,600 guns and 30,000 men. Nelson, much smaller. In men, 17,000 men, smaller in guns, barely 2,000 guns, and 27 ships. That's how the British like it, isn't it, to be outnumbered. That's how we love it.
四层甲板。四层甲板，绝对是一个庞然大物。因此，总的来说，维尔讷夫和格拉维纳拥有33艘船。他们有2,600门大炮和30,000名士兵。纳尔逊的舰队要小得多。在人员方面，17,000人；在火炮方面较少，勉强有2,000门大炮，以及27艘船。这就是英国人喜欢的方式，不是吗，处于人数劣势。这就是我们所喜爱的。
So as we discussed in the previous episode, I mean, this is an amazing fact and cannot be hammered home too strongly. the two fleets at Trafalgar had ten times as much firepower as all the armies at Waterloo put together. I mean, imagine being at the centre of that, the noise and the smoke and the, yeah, it's very first world war, actually. There's never been anything like it in history, right? No, never has, certainly two industrialising nations in Britain and France and a third in Spain. Never have they committed so much of their resources to create a kind of killing zone of this explosive power. It's kind of science fiction quality for everyone who's going to have to live through it.
正如我们在上一集中讨论的那样，我的意思是，这是一个惊人的事实，怎么强调都不过分：特拉法尔加海战中两支舰队的火力是滑铁卢战役所有军队火力总和的十倍。我的意思是，想象一下身处那个中心，噪音、烟雾和，是的，这非常符合第一次世界大战的特征。历史上从来没有过这样的事情，对吧？不，从来没有，当然，工业化国家英国和法国，以及第三个国家西班牙。他们从来没有投入过如此多的资源来创造这种具有爆发力的毁灭性杀戮区。对于所有不得不经历它的人来说，这有一种科幻小说的品质。
It's clear the French and Spanish should gird in their loins for a fight. Nelson says to Blackwood, the enemy are putting a good face on it. And Blackwood says rather ominously, indeed, sir, they have a coolness. I am sorry to witness. But actually, on board certainly some of the Spanish ships, there's anxiety. So one of the captain says the fleet is doomed. And also on Villeneuve's flagship, it had just recently been struck by lightning. And so there are lots of people there who think that's an omen too. So I think there is a sense of trepidation on the combined fleet.
显然，法西两国已经勒紧裤腰带准备战斗了。纳尔逊对布莱克伍德说：“敌人摆出了很好的架势。”布莱克伍德不祥地说道：“确实，长官，他们有一种我感到遗憾的冷静。”但事实上，在某些西班牙船只上，确实存在着焦虑。其中一位舰长说这支舰队注定要毁灭。而且在维尔讷夫的旗舰上，它不久前刚刚被闪电击中。所以那里有很多人认为这也是个不祥之兆。因此我认为联合舰队中确实存在一种恐惧感。
Yeah, I agree with you. But I think we shouldn't be too harsh on poor old Villeneuve. Villeneuve who got a terrible press in Paris, didn't he? People said he was a coward and all of this, which he absolutely wasn't. He has dressed, just like Nelson has, very conspicuously. He's got a Parisian sheik, naval chic. And it's sort of green trousers and gleaming back boots and a big blue coat. And there's a scene before the battle where they parade the Imperial Eagle around the decks. Yeah, which has been given to them personally by Napoleon. By Napoleon.
是的，我同意你的看法。但我认为我们不应对可怜的维尔讷夫过于苛刻。维尔讷夫在巴黎受到了可怕的恶评，不是吗？人们说他是个懦夫诸如此类的，他绝对不是。他和小纳尔逊一样，穿得很引人注目。他有着巴黎式的时髦海军风。那是绿色的裤子、闪亮的黑靴和一件蓝色的大衣。在战役开始前有一个场景，他们把帝国之鹰在甲板上游行展示。是的，那是拿破仑亲自赠予他们的。由拿破仑赠予。
Exactly. I think designed by Napoleon, actually. And they're all shouting, vive l'empereur. And then the Bucenture signals to the combined fleet open fire when the enemy are within range. And that moment is coming closer and closer now. it's 11.30. The British fleet are just a couple of miles away. They have unfurled their flags. So if you imagine the scene, if there's a Hollywood screenwriter listening to this, the big, the cross of St. George, the Union Jack. The victory is flying the white end sign, which is basically a
正是如此。我想实际上是由拿破仑设计的。他们都在高喊“皇帝万岁”（Vive l'empereur）。然后“布散特号”向联合舰队发出信号：当敌人在射程之内时开火。那个时刻越来越近了。现在是11点30分。英国舰队距离只有几英里了。他们已经展开了旗帜。所以如果你想象一下那个场景，如果有一个好莱坞编剧在听这个，巨大的圣乔治十字旗、米字旗。“胜利号”悬挂着白船旗（White Ensign），这基本上是
combination of the two, which is Nelson's personal flag as an Admiral of the White. Magnificent. An Admiral of the White. It's a great spectacle. Now, they've divided into their two columns. Collingwood's column is now ahead, and Nelson is impressed that Collingwood is making such great progress. He says, see how that noble fellow Collingwood carries his ship into action. And at that point, he calls over to a signal lieutenant called John Pascoe, and he says, one more signal to inspire the men. England confides that every man will do his duty. And this is why he, before he left, he'd made sure that all the ships in his fleet had the most up-to-date signal book, isn't it?
两者的结合，这也是纳尔逊作为白舰队海军中将（Admiral of the White）的个人旗帜。壮观。白舰队海军中将。这真是个壮观的景象。现在，他们分成了两个纵队。柯林伍德的纵队现在处于领先地位，纳尔逊对柯林伍德取得如此巨大的进展感到印象深刻。他说：“看那高贵的家伙柯林伍德是如何把他的船带入战斗的。”就在那时，他叫来了一个名叫约翰·帕斯科（John Pascoe）的信号长，并对他说：“再发一个信号来鼓舞士气。英格兰指望每一个人都尽职尽责。”这就是为什么他在离开前确保了他舰队中的所有船只都拥有最新信号手册的原因，不是吗？
For just such a moment. But Nelson has made a mistake. There is no easy signal for the word confides. And so Pascoe hesitates and says to him, confide, sir, really? What about expects? And Nelson says, that will do, Pascoe. Make it directly. And so a moment later, 31 flags go up the mizzen top-gallant mainmast.
正是为了这样的时刻。但纳尔逊犯了一个错误。并没有表示“指望”（confides）这个词的现成信号。于是帕斯科犹豫了一下，对他说：“指望，长官，真的吗？‘期望’（expects）怎么样？”纳尔逊说：“那就行，帕斯科。直接发这个。”所以在片刻之后，31面旗帜升上了米森中桅大桅顶。
I'm sure you can picture which particular mast that is. Yeah, that signal is, of course, England expects that every man will do his duty. And to quote myself in the adventures in time to inspire young readers, in those words there was an extraordinary magic, as if Nelson was speaking personally to every man in the fleet, putting an arm around his shoulders and urging him to do his best. I mean, I've got to say, expect is much better than confides. Yeah, it is. it is exactly it's a it's a simple direct word and there's a little bit of a sense of obligation there isn't there which people would want to rise to yeah again it's like the football manager yeah one sailor said that signal gave us a determination to conquer which is exactly as it should
我确信你能想象出那是哪根特定的桅杆。是的，那个信号当然就是“英格兰期望每人恪尽职守”（England expects that every man will do his duty）。用我在《时间历险记》中引用的话来启发年轻读者：这些字眼具有非凡的魔力，仿佛纳尔逊在亲自对舰队中的每个人说话，把手臂搭在他的肩膀上，敦促他尽最大努力。我的意思是，我必须说，“期望”比“指望”好得多。是的，确实如此。它完全是一个简单直接的词，里面带有一种责任感，人们会想要迎难而上，对吧。是的，这再次就像足球经理一样。一位水手说，那个信号给了我们征服的决心，这正是它应有的样子。
be but it's not the last signal is it so there's two more signals at 1144 yes so one of one of the signals is that the feature prepared to anchor the night after the battle and the reason for that is that Nelson who, you know, from his earliest days on a ship, as a midshipman, had been recording weather patterns. He can read the sea and the weather like nobody else. And he can sense that a storm is brewing. And the kind of the incipient storm is manifesting itself in quite a strong swell that is coming in from the west. And for now, this is good news for the British fleet because it's kind of urging them on. So Collingwood, you know, rushing on towards the French fleet, he's able to to do that because he has this swell behind him. And it's also very bad news for the combined
但这并不是最后一个信号，对吧？在11点44分还有两个信号。是的，其中一个信号是准备在战后之夜下锚。原因在于纳尔逊，你知道的，从他在船上的最早日子起，作为一个见习军官，就一直在记录天气模式。他比任何人都更懂海洋和天气。他能感觉到一场风暴正在酝酿。初露端倪的风暴正表现为从西方涌来相当强烈的涌浪。目前，这对英国舰队来说是个好消息，因为它有点在催促他们前进。所以柯林伍德，你知道的，向法国舰队冲去，他能够做到这一点，因为他背后有这股涌浪。这对联合舰队来说也是个非常坏的消息，因为每当涌浪穿过时，都会让他们的船只上下颠簸。反过来，这意味着他们的火炮很难直接瞄准。我的意思是，本质上，他们只有几秒钟的时间能够与英国船只保持水平。这就确保了基本上当他们开始开火时，他们并没有真正的准确度。所以这对纳尔逊来说是个好消息。所以那是第一个信号，你知道的，展望法国人有望被打败的时候。但现在，当然还有战斗的前景。因此，第二个信号，毫不奇怪，就是“更紧密地与敌人交战”，因为这种混战、贴近、制造混乱，正是纳尔逊的作战计划所追求的。
fleet because every time there is a swell that comes through, it rolls their ships up and down, up and down. And that in turn means it's very difficult for their cannon to aim directly. I mean, essentially, it's only for a few seconds that they will be level with the British ships. And this ensures that essentially when they start firing, they don't really have accuracy. So that's good news for Nelson. So that's the first signal, you know, looking ahead to when the French hopefully have been beaten. But for now there is, of course, the prospect of battle. And so the second signal, unsurprisingly, is engage the enemy more closely because that pell-mell battle getting up close, creating chaos, that is what Nelson's battle plan is all about.
所以我们现在非常接近中午了。护卫舰舰长亨利·布莱克伍德现在正准备离开，返回他的护卫舰。他对纳尔逊告别。他说：“我相信，长官，当我返回‘胜利号’时，我会发现阁下安然无恙，并拥有20个战利品，”意思是20艘被俘虏的敌舰，这是纳尔逊的目标。纳尔逊对他说：“上帝保佑你，布莱克伍德，我再也不会对你说话了。”这是一个非常宿命论的说法。传记作家有时会说，你知道的，纳尔逊是不是有一种对自己死亡的预感？我的意思是，也许这是一种戏剧性的言论，如果他赢了，布莱克伍德就会把它忘得一干二净。
So we're coming very close to midday now. Henry Blackwood, the frigate captain, is now preparing to leave to go back to his frigate. And he says, farewell to Nelson. He says, I trust my lord that on my return to the victory, I shall find your lordship well and in possession of 20 prizes, meaning 20 captured enemy ships, which is Nelson's goal. And Nelson says to him, God bless you, Blackwood, I shall never speak to you again. Which is an extraordinary fatalistic thing to say. And biographers have sometimes said, you know, did Nelson have a kind of pre-sentiment of his own demise? I mean, maybe it's the kind of remark, theatrical remark, that if he'd won, Blackwood would have forgotten it.
我的意思是，我认为这正是那种他被记录在案在战前经常说的话。这几乎就像某种“摸木头”祈吉利的话，对吧？是的，我想是的。11点56分，柯林伍德的“皇家主权号”作为那个纵队的带头船只，现在已经进入了法国火炮的射程。法国舰船“风帆号”（Fugue，此处原文疑为Fougeux意为“勇猛号”，按原文音译作“富吉号”或保留原文）的炮长下令开火。这对于“皇家主权号”来说是毁灭性的，对吧？因为当它接近时，它无法还击。英国人只有在与法国船只并排时才能瞄准自己的火炮。但目前，随着他们接近，法国人只能轰击柯林伍德船只的船首。但柯林伍德，你知道的，毫不气馁、坚定不移，将他的纵队直接带入了敌方炮火的风暴中。他正从圣安娜号和勇猛号两侧遭到舷侧齐射。但是，你知道的，那是他的工作。
I mean, I think it's the kind of comment that he is recorded as having made before battles quite a lot. It's almost like kind of touchwood, isn't it? Yes, I think it is. 1156, Collingwood's royal sovereign, the head of that column, is now within range of the French guns. And the gun captains on the French ship, fugue give the order to fire. And this is devastating for the royal sovereign, isn't it? Because as it's approaching, it can't fire back. The British can only aim their own guns once they are up alongside the French ships. But for now, as they approach it, the French are just able to blast the prow of Collingwood's ship. But Collingwood, you know, undeterred, unwavering, kind of leads his column right into the kind of tempest of enemy fire. He's getting broad sides from two sides from the Santa Ana and the fugue. But, you know, that's his job.
那就是他的一切。他后面跟着他分队的其他船只。有一个故事，我一直觉得好得有些难以置信。因为下一艘船是一艘名为“贝利尔号”（Bellesile，应为Belleisle）的英国船，由威廉·哈古德（William Hargood）指挥。他超过了一艘名为“托内尔号”（Tonnant）的更重的船，由查尔斯·泰勒（Charles Tyler）指挥。当他们擦肩而过时，泰勒向威廉·哈古德大喊：“对于老英格兰来说光荣的一天！”这就像是，他们表现得完全符合他们，这真是太棒了。
That's what he's all about. And he's followed by the other ships from his division. And there's a story that I always think is too good to be true. Because the next ship is a ship called the Belil under an English ship under William Hargood. And he overtakes a heavier ship called the Tonnel under Charles Tyler. And as they're passing each other, Tyler shouts to William Hargud, A glorious day for old England. And it's just like, it's brilliant how they're performing exactly as they.
是的，他们觉得他们必须不负众望。你知道的，这真是美妙的事情。对他们来说，对此没有一丝一毫的讽刺意味。他们完全是真诚的。而且，他们知道这是一场将载入史册的泰坦尼克式的战斗。他们希望，你知道的，他们想要被载入史册。是的，完全正确。他们确实如此。
Yeah, they feel they have to live up to this. You know, that's the wonderful thing. There's no sense of irony about this for them. They complete sincerity. Well, also, they know this is a Titanic battle that will live in the annals of history. And they want, you know, they want to be in those annals. Yeah, I mean, quite right. And they are.
因此，纳尔逊在“胜利号”上怀着钦佩的心情看着柯林伍德的分队带头冲锋。他自己的时刻也快到了。“胜利号”现在非常接近维尔讷夫的旗舰“布散特号”。头顶上开始响起呼啸的枪声，但他说，你知道的，“保持火力，保持火力”，他的炮手们正在保持镇定。然后三艘敌舰同时向他开火：“圣奥古斯丁号”（San Agostin）、“英雄号”（Heros）和“圣地亚哥-特立尼达号”。
So Nelson is watching with admiration from the victory as Collingwood's division leads the way. His own moment has almost come. The victory is now very close to. Villeneuve's flagship, the Bucentor. There are shots beginning to whistle overhead, but he says, you know, hold your fire, hold your fire, and his gun crews are holding their nerve. And then three enemy ships open fire on him at once, the San Agostin, the Hiros, and the Santissima Trinidad.
所以大约有200门大炮。那是非常多的炮。向纳尔逊的船倾泻炮火。空气中已经充满了烟雾、木屑、鲜血之类的东西，然而纳尔逊依然在等待。他现在已经来到了维尔讷夫的旗舰跟前，正在缓缓转向，承受着敌人的炮火，
So that's about 200 guns. That's a lot of guns. Firing into Nelson's ship. And the air is already full of smoke and splinters and blood and whatnot, and yet still Nelson waits. he has got up to Villaner's flagship now and he's slowly turning turning taking the enemy fire
等待着完美的时刻予以还击。但这意味着，当然，他正在承受巨大的惩罚。由于他在后甲板上，他处于火线之中。所以在某个时刻，你知道的，后甲板相当小，在某个时刻，他的秘书——一个名叫约翰·斯科特（John Scott）的家伙——正在跟哈迪舰长说话，
waiting for the perfect moment to return it but that means of course he's absorbing enormous punishment and because he's on the quarter deck he's in the line of fire so at one point you know the quarter deck's quite small at one point his secretary who's a bloke called John Scott is talking to Captain Hardy
这时一颗敌人的炮弹正好砸进他的中间，基本上把他炸成了碎片。他只剩下两条腿还站着，对吧？是的，那是一个可怕的场景。两名水手基本上把剩下的部分拿起来扔过了船舷。纳尔逊扫了一眼他的肩膀说：“哦，那是可怜的斯科特牺牲了吗？
when an enemy cannonball just smashes into the middle of him and basically blows him to pieces. He's kind of two legs are left standing, aren't they? Yeah, it's a ghastly scene. And two sailors basically take the rest of him and throw it over the side. And Nelson, he kind of glances over his shoulder and he says, oh, is that poor Scott that's gone?
可怜的家伙。”是的，非常像滑铁卢战役时的威灵顿公爵。非常像威灵顿公爵。然后船舵在木屑云中爆炸了。另一发炮弹一下子炸死了后甲板上的八名海军陆战队员。纳尔逊对海军陆战队队长说：“把你们的人分散开。你知道的，不要挤在一起，
Poor fellow. Yeah, very Duke of Wellington at the Battle of Altloo. Very Duke of Wellington. Then the ship's wheel explodes in a kind of cloud of splinters. There's another shot that kills eight Marines in one go on the poop deck. And Nelson says to the Marine Captain, and spread out your men. You know, don't pack them together
因为如果他们挤在一起，会更容易被杀死。”越来越多的炮弹砸向后甲板。其中一颗炮弹名声大噪地从哈迪的鞋子上弹开，扯掉了鞋扣。你知道的，这对于哈迪来说非常幸运
because if they're, you know, they'll be more easily killed if they're packed together. And there are more and more shots kind of hammering into the quarter deck. One of them famously ricochets off Hardy's shoe and rips off the buckle. And, you know, it's very lucky for Hardy
因为如果它们，你知道的，挤在一起就会更容易被杀死。越来越多的炮弹接连不断地轰击后甲板。其中一颗炮弹非常著名地从哈迪的鞋子上反弹开，扯掉了鞋扣。而且，你知道的，这对哈迪来说非常幸运
basically could have lost his foot. And Nelson says to Hardy, this is too warm work Hardy to last long, meaning we can't take much more of this. Because they've now lost, what, about 50 men dead and wounded on the deck of the victory. Their sail has been reduced to ribbons. The wheel has been destroyed.
基本上差点失去了脚。纳尔逊对哈迪说，这场仗打得太激烈了，哈迪，不会持续太久的，意思是说我们顶不了多久了。因为现在胜利号的甲板上已经有大约50人死伤。他们的船帆被打得粉碎，舵也被摧毁了。
But while that has been happening, they have completed the turn and they are ready to fire. And so Victory has 50 cannons trained on the Boussantor and smash the French flagship seems almost to kind of crumple in submission before this firepower. And now it is the turn of the French flagship. its deck to be covered with bodies, soaked in blood, its guns wrecked, its officers smashed to pieces, although Villeneuve survives, doesn't he? And it is a scene of the utmost devastation, and that is what Nelson's entire battle plan had been.
但就在这期间，他们完成了转向，随时准备开火。因此，胜利号将50门大炮对准了布桑托尔号，重创了法国旗舰，这艘旗舰在强大的火力面前几乎要在屈服中瘫痪了。现在轮到法国旗舰了，它的甲板上布满了尸体，浸透了鲜血，大炮被毁，军官们粉身碎骨，不过维尔讷夫活了下来，不是吗？这是一个极其惨烈的场面，而这正是纳尔逊整个作战计划的目的。
This is the chaos that he has created on the assumption that he will be able to capitalize on it, and so it has turned out. But we can't, you know, emphasize too much just how bloody and horrific. this is. I mean, this is not, you know, anyone who thinks, oh, I'd love to see the Battle of Trafalgar. I mean, it's an unbelievably traumatising and horrific scene. So we mentioned one of the guys who wrote a letter to his parents, Robert Smith dying. He was killed by enemy shot and they ripped off both of his legs. Hardee's Clark was killed on his way down to the surgeon. The Marine captain, Charles Adair, was killed while pulling his men back to try to shield them from the fire. But all the time, this is the amazing thing.
这就是他制造的混乱，他认为自己能够利用这种混乱，事实也确实如此。但是，我们怎么强调这场战斗的血腥和恐怖都不过分。我的意思是，这并不是说，任何认为“哦，我很想看看特拉法尔加海战”的人所想的那样。我的意思是，这是一个令人难以置信的创伤和恐怖的场景。所以我们提到了其中一个给父母写信的人罗伯特·史密斯快要死了。他被敌人的炮弹击中，双腿被炸飞。哈迪的书记官在去找外科医生的路上丧生。海军陆战队上尉查尔斯·阿代尔在将部下拉回以试图保护他们免受炮火攻击时牺牲了。然而，最令人惊奇的是，在这一切发生的同时。
They stick to their guns, they stick to their posts. This is what they've been trained for, to absorb all this enemy punishment. And they do it because they know they will win, because they are winning. Well, the deck is a wash with blood. But below deck, the gunners there are kind of much more protected by, you know, they're not as exposed. And so therefore they are able to continue just pounding and pounding and pounding. And the British gunners are just much more efficient.
他们坚守岗位，坚守阵位。这就是他们所受的训练，承受敌人所有的打击。他们之所以这么做，是因为他们知道自己会赢，因为他们正在赢得胜利。好吧，甲板上血流成河。但在甲板下方，炮手们受到的保护要多得多，你知道，他们没有暴露在外面。因此，他们能够继续不断地猛烈轰击。英国炮手要高效得多。
much quicker than their French adversaries. I mean, that's what basically makes them so lethal. Yeah, but it's not over yet. Because, of course, the victory is still kind of isolated at the head of its column. Three enemy ships at once kind of converge on the victory, hemming it in, and an attempt to kind of break out of their deadly embrace, he drives the victory into one of the French 74s,
比他们的法国对手快得多。我的意思是，这基本上就是他们如此致命的原因。是的，但还没结束。因为，当然，胜利号仍然孤立在队伍的最前端。三艘敌舰同时向胜利号靠拢，将其包围，为了摆脱这种致命的纠缠，他将胜利号驶向了一艘法国74门炮舰，
which is called the Rudutabl, and he sends the Rudutab swinging backwards. So there's more shots on every side. the Rudutab is preparing to board because of course that was Villeneuve's plan turned the sea battle into a land battle use all the infantry on our ships to get aboard the British ships
这艘船叫“红心”号（Redoutable），他让“红心”号向后旋转。因此，四面八方都有炮弹袭来。“红心”号正准备登船作战，因为这当然是维尔讷夫的计划——把海战变成陆战，利用我们船上的所有步兵登上英国军舰。
and create havoc so the Rudutab's men are throwing grappling hooks they're pulling the two ships together getting ready to launch their assault and there's kind of loads of musket fire coming in and a hail of grenades there are clouds of black smoke coming from above the victory
制造混乱，“红心”号的人在扔抓钩，他们把两艘船拉到一起，准备发起攻击，头顶上飞来大量的火枪弹雨和冰雹般的手榴弹，胜利号上方升起团团黑烟。
and then Tom comes the moment, and maybe you would like to read from the earth-shatteringly definitive account. Yes, Adventures in Time by Dominic Sambrook. On the quarter-deck, Nelson and Hardy were deep in conversation as so often in the past. On his admiral's coat, the golden buttons gleamed in the sunlight. High above the deck of the Redoubtable, a French marksman levelled his musket. Through the smoke, he could see a flash of guilt, as two little figures moved on the British flagship.
然后，时刻到了，也许你想从那部震撼人心的权威著作中读上一段？是的，由多米尼克·桑布鲁克撰写的《时间历险记》。在后甲板上，纳尔逊和哈迪像过去一样在深入交谈。在他海军上将的外套上，金色的纽扣在阳光下闪闪发光。“红心”号甲板高处，一名法国狙击手端起了火枪。透过烟雾，他看到了一闪而过的镀金，两个小小的身影在英国旗舰上移动。
On the victory, Nelson turned to speak to Hardy. The marksman's finger tightened on the trigger. It was 1.15 in the afternoon. In Burnham Thorpe, the birds were singing. The marksman fired. We'll take a break. This episode is brought to you by Uber. Now, do you know that feeling when someone
在胜利号上，纳尔逊转过身对哈迪说话。狙击手的手指扣紧了扳机。当时是下午1点15分。在伯纳姆索普，鸟儿在歌唱。狙击手开枪了。我们休息一下。本集由Uber为您赞助。现在，你知道那种感觉吗？当有人。
shows up for you when you need it most. We all need that sometimes, and Uber knows it. Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered, it's showing up no matter what. Like for your long distance friends, bringing soup when they're sick, sending flowers when they're down. When it really matters, whatever it is, you show up. Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber, on our way. Download the app today. Hello and welcome back to a very emotional rest is history. Dominic, a shot has rung out from the friendship, the Aredu Tabler, but the clamour of the battle being what it is, nobody has heard it.
在你最需要的时候出现。我们有时都需要这种支持，Uber深知这一点。Uber不仅仅是提供一次乘车或一份外卖，它意味着无论发生什么都会出现。就像对于你远方的朋友，他们生病时送去汤，情绪低落时送去鲜花。当真正重要的时候，无论是什么，你都会出现。有志者，事竟成，我们在路上了。Uber，在路上了。立即下载应用程序。哈啰，欢迎回到充满情感的“历史的其余部分”。多米尼克，一声枪响从敌舰“红心”号上传出，但由于战斗的喧嚣，没有人听到。
And it's only when Hardy, who's been kind of pacing ahead, turns back to look for Nelson that he realizes what has happened. because he sees Nelson lying on his side, he's in excruciating agony, he's propping himself up with his left hand. And Hardy can see that a musket ball has hit Nelson on the left shoulder, punched through his spine and is buried inside his body. And Hardy and other sailors rush to his side and Nelson looks up at Hardy and says, I believe they have done it at last. My backbone is shot through. And Hardy orders men to pick the Admiral up, to carry him down to the surgeon's cockpit. And of course, every step that the men carrying Nelson take, it's absolute agony for Nelson
直到一直走在前面的哈迪转身寻找纳尔逊时，他才意识到发生了什么。因为他看到纳尔逊侧躺着，正痛苦万分，他用左手撑起身体。哈迪看到一颗火枪弹击中了纳尔逊的左肩膀，穿透了他的脊椎，嵌在他的体内。哈迪和其他水手冲到他身旁，纳尔逊抬头看着哈迪说：“我想他们终于得手了。我的脊椎被打穿了。”哈迪命令部下把海军上将扶起来，抬到外科医生的手术舱。当然，抬着纳尔逊的人走的每一步，对纳尔逊来说都是绝对的痛苦。
himself. And such is his pain that he asks for a handkerchief to cover his face because he doesn't want to alarm his men with how seriously injured he is. He knows that probably he's dying. So he's taken down it into the cockpit and there in the shambles, he is laid down. Yeah. It's a terrible place that's to the cockpit. It's very dark. It's lit by these kind of shaking lanterns. There's a smell of sweat and blood.
他痛苦难忍，要求用手帕蒙住脸，因为他不想让部下看到自己受伤有多严重。他知道自己可能快死了。于是他被抬进了手术舱，在那片混乱中，他被放倒了。是的。手术舱是个可怕的地方。那里非常昏暗。靠着这些摇晃的灯笼照明。弥漫着汗水和血腥味。
There's blood everywhere. There's blood on the timbers. There's the bodies of wounded men everywhere. They can hear up ahead the roar of the guns, the cheering and screaming and whatnot. And whenever the ship lurches, you know, some of the wounded men, men cry out in pain and they lie Nelson down on a midshipman's cot and they take off his clothes. The surgeon, Dr. Beatty, William Beatty, comes at once and they can tell from his face right away, you know, what this means. And Nelson says to Beatty, uh, Mr. Beattie, you can do
到处都是血。木梁上有血。到处都是受伤水手的尸体。他们能听到前方传来的隆隆炮声、欢呼声和尖叫声等等。每当船身倾斜时，你知道，一些受伤的水手会痛苦地尖叫，他们把纳尔逊放在一张见习军官的床上，脱下他的衣服。外科医生贝蒂博士（Dr. Beatty，威廉·贝蒂）立刻赶来，他们从他的脸上立刻就能看出这意味着什么。纳尔逊对贝蒂说：“呃，贝蒂先生，你对我也无能为力了。我没多少日子可活了。我的后背被打穿了。”贝蒂为他检查。此时，纳尔逊身边围绕着他的一些至密战友，牧师亚历山大·斯科特，他接下来的几周基本上都不会离开纳尔逊的身旁，还有他的管家威廉·舍瓦利埃等人。贝蒂强忍着泪水。他看着纳尔逊说：“我的勋爵，对于我们的国家来说，不幸的是，没有什么能为您做了。”纳尔逊说：“医生，我早就告诉你了。医生，我快不行了。”接下来发生了什么？有不同的说法。可能最好的版本，我认为是在约翰·萨格登（John Sugden）那本非凡的传记中，他筛选了所有的证据。整个下午，纳尔逊都在谈论汉密尔顿夫人，对吧，汤姆？
nothing for me. I have but a short time to live. My back is shot through and Beatty examines him. Now, around Nelson are some of his closest comrades as chaplain, Alex. Sanda Scott, who will basically not leave his side now for weeks to come, and his steward, William Chevalier and others. And Beatty is fighting back tears. And he looks at Nelson. He says, My lord, unhappily for our country, there is nothing that can be done for you. And Nelson says, Doctor, I told you so. Doctor, I'm gone. Now what happens next? There are different accounts. Probably the best version of this, I think, is in John Sugden's extraordinary biography, which kind of, you know, sifts all the evidence. Nelson, throughout the afternoon, is talking about Lady Hamilton, isn't he, Tom?
代我向汉密尔顿夫人问好。代我向霍拉西亚问好。我必须把汉密尔顿夫人、我收养的女儿霍拉西亚作为遗产留给我的国家。有趣的是，他到这个时候仍然说，我收养的女儿，房间里的每个人都知道那是他的亲生女儿，而不是收养的。但他还是……这是肌肉记忆，对吧？他一直在反反复复地这么说。但是，我的意思是，她们一直在他心头。
Remember me to Lady Hamilton. Remember me to Horatia. I have to leave Lady Hamilton, my adopted daughter, Horatia, as a legacy to my country. It's interesting that he still says at this point, my adopted daughter, everybody in that room knows that she's his daughter and not adopted. But he's still... It's the muscle memory, isn't it? He's been saying it over and over again. But, I mean, they're on his mind.
她们是他不断牵挂的人。这种迫切的焦虑是，如果他死了，她们会怎么样？是的。从一开始，他就对贝蒂说：“别在我身上浪费时间了。你知道，我没救了。把时间花在真正需要你的士兵身上。”发生的情况是，他的脊椎被这颗火枪弹粉碎了，他失去了下半身的所有知觉。但每当船晃动时，每当头顶上的大炮轰鸣时，他都会痛苦地畏缩。
They are the people he keeps returning to. And this pressing anxiety that if he dies, what will happen to them? Yeah. Now, right from the beginning, he says to Beatty, don't waste your time with me. You know, I'm done for. Spend your time on the men who really need you. What's happened is his backbone has been shattered by this musketball and he's losing all sense in his lower body. But whenever the ship, you know, moves, whenever the guns crash overhead, he kind of gives great wince and agony.
他被闷热和黑暗窒息着。他不断地试图甩掉盖在身上的床单。他不停地低声呢喃着：“扇子，扇子，喝的，喝的。”他们给他拿来一些水和柠檬水。但他太虚弱了，只能勉强啜饮几滴。斯科特牧师跪下来跟他一起祈祷了一会儿。但很明显，生命快要走到尽头了。纳尔逊听到前方传来欢呼声，他开始寻找哈迪。
He is being suffocated by heat and by the kind of darkness. He's constantly trying to throw off the sheet they put over him. And he keeps whispering, fan, fan, drink, drink. And they bring him some water and lemonade. But he's so weak, he can barely sip, you know, more than a few kind of drops. And the Reverend Scott kneels and prays with him for a little bit. But it's clear, you know, the end is coming. Nelson is cheering up ahead and he starts to ask for Hardy.
哈迪在哪里？把哈迪带给我。你觉得他是在死死抓住生命不放，直到他知道结果。他极度渴望他渴望已久的胜利，在听到消息之前他是不会放弃的。事实上，离他几步远躺着受伤的人是约翰·帕斯科（John Pascoe），信号中尉，那个提出“英格兰期待……”的人，他被霰弹严重炸伤。帕斯科低声对他说：“如果有欢呼声，这一定是个好迹象。法国人一定投降了。”
Where's Hardy? Bring me Hardy. You have the sense of him, I think, that he is clinging to life until he knows. He's desperate for the victory that he is craved for so long and he will not give up until he hears the news. And actually, the bloke who's a few feet away from him lying wounded, is John Pascoe, the signals lieutenant, the England expects guy, who's been badly wounded by grapeshot. And Pascoe whispers to him, if there's cheer. That must be a good sign. The French must be surrendering.
他们确实投降了，不是吗？因为在“红心”号上方，特米雷尔号（Temeraire，特纳名画中的那艘船）已经将其制服。到了下午一点半左右，“红心”号上大约有500名船员阵亡。于是船长降下了旗帜。差不多在这个时候，那个狙击手被胜利号甲板上的英国海军陆战队员击毙了。是的，但纳尔逊当然不可能知道这一切的所有细节。
And they are, aren't they? Because up above the Redutabler has been overpowered by the Temerare, which is the ship in Turner's great painting. And by half-past one in the afternoon, about 500 of the crew of the Redu-Tabler are lying dead. And so the captain hauls down their flag. and probably the sniper who shot Nelson by this point, he's dead shot by the British Marines from the deck of the victory. Yeah, but of course Nelson can't really know
所以这让他感到焦虑，这也是他一直寻找哈迪的原因。而哈迪因为身处激战中心，直到大约两点半才下来。他紧紧握住纳尔逊的手。看到纳尔逊的状况，他大惊失色。纳尔逊显然痛苦不堪，说道：
all the details of this. So that's what's making him anxious and why he's always asking for Hardy. And Hardy, because he's in the thick of the battle, doesn't come down until about 2.30. And he clasps Nelson's hand. He's shocked when he sees Nelson's condition. Nelson, who's clearly in agony, says,
“哈迪，我们今天的战况如何？”哈迪说：“非常好，勋爵，到目前为止，我们已经俘获了大约12到14艘敌舰，我毫不怀疑剩下的也会被狠狠地教训一顿。”纳尔逊说：“我是一个死人，哈迪，我快不行了。我很快就要完了，靠近我，求求你，让我亲爱的汉密尔顿夫人得到我的头发和属于我的一切。”哈迪坐下来握着他的手一会儿。纳尔逊（你知道，哈迪显然完全心碎了，这个高大可怕的男人，事实上），纳尔逊在意识清醒和昏迷之间徘徊。哈迪之所以能坐在纳尔逊身边，主要是因为到了这个时候，
well Hardy how goes the day with us and Hardy says very well my lord he says so far we've captured about 12 of 14 of their ships and I have no doubt of giving the rest a drubbing and Nelson says I'm a dead man Hardy I'm going fast it'll be all over with me soon come nearer to me pray let my dear lady Hamilton have my hair and all other things belonging to me and Hardy sits and holds his hand for a little bit and Nelson who is you know hard is clearly completely distraught, this huge and terrifying man, actually, and Nelson is sort of passing in and out of consciousness. And the reason that Hardy feels able to sit with Nelson is essentially because by this
战局已定。英国人显然赢了。必须承认，法军和西法联军表现出了极大的勇气，但是，正如维尔讷夫一直所知道的那样，他们的火力不如英国人，因为英国人在海上的战斗力实在太强了。维尔讷夫本人表现出了极大的英勇和勇气。他坚守岗位直到最后，可能希望获得英雄般的死法，但没有实现。因此在大约两点半左右，他也降下了军旗，他的船被登船占领了。
point the battle is no longer in the balance. The British have clearly won. I mean, it has to be said that the French and the Spanish have fought with tremendous courage, but, you know, as Villeneuve all along had known would happen, they had been outgunned by the British, because the British are just too good to confront at sea. And Villeneuve himself paved with great gallantry, with great courage. He remains at his post to the very end, probably hoping for heroic death, but it doesn't come. And so around 2.30, he too hauls down his colours and his ship is boarded.
英国人拿走了拿破仑亲自授予维尔讷夫的鹰旗，并把它扔进了海里。是的，一个非常醒目的象征性时刻。联合舰队的一些成员又抵抗了几个小时，但到了下午晚些时候，一切都结束了。这是对一切的证明，是对纳尔逊整个职业生涯的证明。因为我想这不仅关乎纳尔逊，对吧？这关乎水手、造船厂、车间、工厂。
and the British take the eagle that had been given to Villeneuve personally by Napoleon and they toss it overboard. Yeah, a very striking symbolic moment. Some of the combined fleet fought on for a few hours more, but by late afternoon it was all over. And it's the vindication of everything, of Nelson's entire career. Because I guess it's not just about Nelson, is it? It's about the sailors, the shipyards, the workshops, the factories.
我的意思是，我们对查塔姆高街进行了一次著名的访问。这就是它所代表的。是那些制作船帆的人。是女裁缝。是职员、化学家、木匠、铁匠，还有皮特和科林伍德。因为这是一场全民总动员的全民战争。他们为了这一刻，为了这个时刻而被动员起来。但我认为它甚至还要更进一步，
I mean, we did a famous tour of Chatham High Street. It's what that represents. It's the people who make the sails. It's the seamstresses. It's the clerks and the chemists and the carpenters and the blacksmiths and Pitt and Collingwood. It's because this was a total war in which the entire nation was mobilized. And they were mobilized for this moment in time, for this point. But I would say it goes even, you know, it's even.
比这更多，这是一项可以追溯到几十年前的投资。这可能是民族国家迄今为止进行的最持久、最有效的投资。本质上，如果今天的英国政府想要一个如何把事情做好、如何让长期投资得到回报的例子，那么我认为回顾特拉法尔加海战并看看是什么让它成为可能，将会是一个非常好的教训，因为特拉法尔加海战在几几十年前就已经赢得了。汤姆，我脑海中有一个画面，
more than that, this is an investment that goes back decades. And it's probably the most sustained, the most effective investment ever undertaken up to that point by a nation state. And essentially, if the British government today wants an example of how to get things done and how to make long-term investment pay off, then I think looking to Trafalgar and seeing what made it possible would be a very good lesson because Trafalgar was won decades before. I have an image in my mind, Tom,
雷切尔·里夫斯（Rachel Reeves）和普里蒂·菲利普森（Pritchett Philipson）泪流满面地听着这个播客，爱国主义热情的泪水顺着脸颊流淌，因为我确信这正是他们喜欢的那种东西。对。
of Rachel Reeves and Pritchett Philipson and like, we're listening to this podcast with tears streaming down, tears of patriotic enthusiasm streaming down their cheeks because I'm sure this is exactly the kind of thing they love. Right.
当然，这首先是为策划这场战役的人取得的胜利。那个开辟道路并为胜利真正牺牲了自己的人。现在，在他辉煌的时刻，故事正走向尾声。下午3点30分左右，哈迪离开后又回到了纳尔逊身边。他说，我们取得了辉煌的胜利。
It's a victory, of course, above all, though, for the man who planned it. The man who led the way and effectively sacrificed himself for victory. And now, in his supreme hour, the story is drawing to a close. At about 3.30, Hardy comes back to Nelson, having left him. And he says, we have won a magnificent victory.
我们至少俘获了15艘船，可能更多。他说，这一切都归功于你，人们将永远谈论这一天。纳尔逊极其微弱地说：“15艘？很好，但我想要的是20艘。”我的意思是，这是史无前例的，对吧？在尼罗河战役中，纳尔逊俘获了7艘，这被视为前所未有的成就。这让你对他在特拉法尔加海战中取得的成就的规模有了一些概念。简直难以置信。
We've taken at least 15 ships, maybe more. He says, all this is down to you, and people will talk of this day forever. And Nelson, very faintly says, 15. That is well, but I bargained for 20. And I mean, this is unprecedented, isn't it? At the Battle of the Nile, Nelson took seven, and that was seen as an unprecedented achievement. So that gives you some sense of the scale of what he has achieved at Trafalgar. Just unbelievable.
哈迪对纳尔逊说：“现在应该让科林伍德海军上将接管舰队吗？”纳尔逊说：“只要我还活着，我希望不要，哈迪。”你知道，即使到了现在，纳尔逊也不想放弃指挥权。现在，他提醒哈迪：“一定要记得过夜下锚，因为暴风雨要来了。”事实上，你知道，他是对的，因为事实证明，那场暴风雨会夺去很多人的生命。纳尔逊现在真的非常非常艰难地呼吸着。再次叮嘱：“照顾好我亲爱的汉密尔顿夫人，哈迪。照顾好可怜的汉密尔顿夫人。”然后是每个男孩子和女孩子以前都要学的那个非常著名的时刻：“我将死去，哈迪。长官，您痛苦吗？是的，但我还能活半小时。哈迪，吻我。”哈迪跪下来吻了他的脸颊。一个非常感人的场景。
Hardy says to Nelson, should Admiral Collingwood take command of the fleet now? And Nelson says, not where I live, I hope, Hardy. You know, even now Nelson doesn't want to give up the command. Now, he reminds Hardy, he says, make sure you anchor overnight because that storm is coming. And actually, you know, he's right because that storm will kill a lot of people, as it turns out. He is now really, really struggling to breathe, Nelson. Again, take care of my dear Lady Hamilton, Hardy. Take care of poor Lady Hamilton. And then the very famous moment that every schoolboy and schoolgirl used to learn. I shall die, Hardy. Is your pain great, sir? Yes, but I shall live
纳尔逊说：“感谢上帝，我尽了我的职责，”然后闭上了眼睛。哈迪挺直身子，然后改变主意，再次跪下来吻了纳尔逊的额头。纳尔逊说：“那是谁？”“是我，哈迪。”“上帝保佑你，哈迪，”纳尔逊说。然后哈迪转过身去，他太难过了。你知道，对于那个小房间里的人来说，最引人注目的是，哈迪平时那么吓人，
half an hour yet. Hardy kiss me. And Hardy kneels down and kisses his cheek. A very moving scene. and Nelson says, thank God I've done my duty and closes his eyes. Hardy straightens up and then changes his mind and kneels down again and kisses Nelson's brow. And Nelson says, who is that? It's Hardy. God bless you, Hardy, says Nelson. And then Hardy turns away he's so overcome. You know, it was so striking for people in that little room that Hardy, who was so terrifying,
通常，你知道，最喜欢鞭打手下的他，竟然如此痛苦，眼中含泪，诸如此类。尽管他赢了，你知道，他指挥了海军历史上赢得最著名胜利的旗舰，但他被朋友的困境深深触动了。是的，当然。我的意思是，我正在擦去一个男子汉的眼泪。接下来的一个小时里，纳尔逊躺在那里。他在半睡半醒之间。他的管家舍瓦利埃把他翻到右侧，这是唯一能稍微减轻他痛苦的姿势。但纳尔逊痛苦极了，他只是喃喃自语：“喝的，喝的，扇子，扇子，揉揉，揉揉。”他睁开眼睛，看到他的牧师斯科特神父，他说：
usually, you know, who loved nothing better than flogging his men, was so, so stricken, you know, kind of tears in his eyes and all this kind. Even though he is won, you know, he is, he is captained the flagship that has won the most famous victory in naval history, but he's so affected by his friend's plight. Yeah, of course. I mean, I'm wiping away a manly tear. So for another hour, Nelson lies there. He's drifting in and out of sleep. His steward, Chevalier, turns him onto his right side, which is the only position that eases his pain a bit. But Nelson's in dreadful agony, and he's just whispering drink. drink fan fan rub rub he opens his eyes and he sees his chaplain the reverend scott and he says
“我真希望没有离开甲板，因为我很快就要走了。记住，我把汉密尔顿夫人和我的女儿霍拉西亚作为遗产留给我的国家。永远不要忘记霍拉西亚。”然后他们默默地呆了几分钟。纳尔逊侧躺着，闭着眼睛，他们揉着他的胸膛，支撑着他，不让他彻底瘫倒。他现在呼吸真的很困难，斯科特神父听到他一遍又一遍地低声呢喃：“感谢上帝，我尽了我的职责。”他非常轻声地呢喃着他的遗言：“上帝和我的国家。”然后一切都结束了。故事到此结束，全场没有一个干眼睛。哦天哪，但还没完全结束，对吧？因为还有一些善后工作要做，多米尼克。
i wish i had not left the deck for soon i shall be gone remember that i leave lady hamilton and my daughter horatia as a legacy to my country never forget horatia and then for a few minutes they're there in silence nelson is on his side he's got his eyes closed they're rubbing his chest and sort of propping him up to stop him just slumping over completely he's really struggling to breathe now, and the Reverend Scott hears him whispering again and again, thank God I've done my duty. And very softly, he whispers his last words, God and my country. And then it's over. That's the end of the story, not a dry eye in the house. Oh dear, but not quite the end, is it? Because just a little bit of housekeeping, Dominic.
你知道，胜利的规模，特拉法尔加战役的最终战果，简直惊人。英国损失了大约500人。另外1200人受伤，法国和西班牙的伤亡人数大约是英国的10倍。舰船方面，纳尔逊在尼罗河战役中俘获了7艘。在这里，他们俘获了17艘船，击沉了第18艘，这是海军作战史上最惊人的战果。当这个消息传回英国时，人们简直不敢相信。我的意思是，他们被彻底震撼了。
You know, the scale of the victory, so the final tally at Trafalgar, I mean, stunning. The British have lost about 500 people. another 1,200 wounded, French and Spanish, about 10 times more. The ships, Nelson captured 7 at the Nile. Here, they have captured 17 ships, destroyed an 18th, and this is the most stunning hall in the entire history of naval combat. And when the news of it gets back to England, people can't believe it. I mean, they're just blown away.
尽管纳尔逊当然死于未能达到20艘的遗憾。因此，他总是、总是要求最好。但当然，对于他的舰队官兵来说，这绝对是一场苦乐参半的胜利，不是吗？因为他们绝对从中认出了“纳尔逊风格”，而现在纳尔逊已经离去了。是的，事实上，当听到他死讯时，舰队中公开痛哭的人如此之多，这真是非凡。因此，当哈迪派人去“皇家君主号”告诉科林伍德海军上将纳尔逊已经去世时，他们含泪登上了“皇家君主号”。科林伍德的一名水手说：
Although, of course, Nelson dies disappointed that it wasn't 20. So always, always demanding the best. But of course, for the men of his fleet, I mean, it's an incredibly bittersweet victory, isn't it? Because they absolutely recognise in it the Nelson touch, and now Nelson has gone. Yeah, it's extraordinary, actually, how many stories there are people openly weeping in the fleet when they heard the news that he was dead. So when Hardy sent a party to the Royal Sovereign to tell Admiral Collingwood that Nelson had died, they went aboard the Royal Sophrin with tears streaming down their faces. One of Collingwood's sailors said,
“看到那些拼死战斗的汉子们坐下来像女人一样哭泣，真是奇怪。”特别是舰长们，也就是几周前还和纳尔逊共进晚餐的人。他们赢得了历史上最惊人的胜利，但他们就像心碎的人一样，因为没有了他，胜利仿佛失去了意义。护卫舰船长亨利·布莱克伍德对他的妻子说：“我失去了最勇敢的人和最好的朋友。”斯科特神父说：“我可以永远向你讲述这个深受爱戴的人的品质。”
it was strange to see chaps that fought like the devil sit down and cry like a wench. The captains in particular, so the people who had had those dinners with Nelson, you know, just a few weeks before. They've won the most amazing victory in history, but they are like broken men because it almost feels like it's been stripped of its meaning without him. Henry Blackwood, the frigate captain, said to his wife, I've lost the most gallant of men and the best of friends. The Reverend Scott, I could forever tell you the qualities of this beloved man.
“在10月21日之前的好几年里，我都没有流过一滴泪，但自那以后，每当我独自一人，我就像个孩子一样。”是的，我想对于科林伍德来说尤其震惊，他可能是纳尔逊在舰队中最亲密的朋友，从一开始就认识纳尔逊。所以他写道：“我无法告诉你我受到的打击有多深。我对他的友情是海军中绝无仅有的，一段超过30年的兄弟情谊。”所以他现在指挥着英国舰队，恐怕，你知道，我爱科林伍德，没有人比我更崇拜科林伍德了。
I haven't shed a tear for years before the 21st of October, but since, whenever alone, I'm quite a child. Yeah, and I guess a particular shock for Collingwood, he's probably Nelson's closest friend in the fleet, and had known Nelson since the very beginning. So he wrote, I cannot tell you how deeply I am affected. My friendship for him was unlike anything that I have left in the Navy. a brotherhood of more than 30 years and so he is now in command of the British fleet and I'm afraid, you know, I love Collingwood no one admires Collingwood more than me
但他确实稍微有点让人失望，因为纳尔逊整天都在敦促舰队连夜下锚，因为暴风雨要来了，而科林伍德却疏忽了下达这个命令。果不其然，暴风雨真的来了，大概有多少，2000、3000名法国和西班牙俘虏最终被淹死了。
but he does slightly let himself down because of course Nelson all day had been urging the fleet to anchor overnight because this storm is coming in and Collingwood neglects to give that order and sure enough a storm does come in and what is it kind of 2,000, 3,000 French and Spanish prisoners end up drowning.
许多战利品不得不被抛弃。所以这是科林伍德履历上的一个小污点，但也只是极其微小的一个。我的意思是，这就是那个首先冲破法国战线的人。是的，完全正确。所以在10月26日暴风雨过后，科林伍德派了一艘船带着消息去伦敦。一艘叫“腌黄瓜号”（Pickle）的快船。这作为船名太糟糕了。确实如此。
Lots of the prizes have to be abandoned. So that's a slight blot on Collingwood's copybook, but only the slightest. I mean, this is the man who hit the French line first. Yeah, exactly. So on the 26th of October when the storm was over, Collingwood sent a ship to London with the news. A cutter called the Pickle. Which is a terrible name for a ship. It is.
真的很逊。就像找到世界杯的那条狗一样，对吧？是的。由一位名叫约翰·理查兹·拉皮诺蒂埃（John Richards Lapinotier）的军官率领，我必须说，他令舰队其他人羡慕嫉妒恨，基本上靠这个名声过了一辈子。他于11月4日抵达法尔茅斯。然后他坐上了去伦敦的第一辆马车。
It's really underwhelming. It's like the dog that found the World Cup, isn't it? Yeah. So under an officer called John Richards Lapinotier, who was the envy of the fleet, I have to say, and basically traded on this for the rest of his life. And he arrived in Falmouth on the 4th of November. And he got on the first coach to London.
他在大雾中抵达海军部，并递交了科林伍德的报告。科林伍德说：“我们取得了彻底而辉煌的胜利。”但他接着写道，这是一段非常著名的段落，记录了一位英雄的牺牲，他的名字将永垂不朽，他的记忆将永远留在他的国家心中。科林伍德接着说道：
He arrived at the Admiralty in heavy fog, and he handed over Collingwood's report. And Collingwood said, we've won a complete and glorious victory. But he went on, it's a very famous kind of passage, to record the loss of a hero whose name will be immortal and his memory ever dear to his country and Connywood went on to say
“我的心为失去一位朋友而感到最剧烈的悲痛，多年来，我与这位朋友由最深厚的深情纽带紧密相连。”这份报告被复制并直接送到了唐宁街威廉·皮特（小皮特）的手中。皮特在凌晨时分收到了这份报告。
my heart is rent with the most poignant grief for the death of a friend to whom for all these years I was bound by the strongest ties of affection and that report was copied and taken straight to Downing Street to William Pitt, Pitt the younger. Pitt gets it kind of in the small hours of the morning.
皮特总是说，无论消息如何，无论战争进行得多么糟糕，一定要睡个好觉。他事后说，这是他政治生涯中唯一一个无法入眠的夜晚，因为他深受失去纳尔逊的打击。乔治三世当时在温莎城堡。他在早餐前刚刚收到这份报告，据说他坐在那里一言不发，
Pitt always said, whatever the news, no matter how badly the war is going, always get a good night's sleep. And he said afterwards this was the one night in his political career when he couldn't sleep because he was so affected by the loss of Nelson. George III was at Windsor Castle. He got the report just before breakfast and he supposedly sat there in silence, unable
激动得说不出话来。汤姆，你觉得这是出于内疚。嗯，我希望如此，因为他冷落了纳尔逊，不是吗？他对这位伟人的支持本可以更多。是的，你知道，天亮时分，消息传遍了伦敦，报纸印制了号外，一大群人聚集在海军部门前，一片死寂。这太惊人了。你知道，英国皇家海军赢得了渴望已久的胜利，英国彻底免受侵略，成为了海洋的女王，然而失去纳尔逊却成了他们头条新闻的第一条。是的，罗伯特·骚塞（Robert Southey），后来成为桂冠诗人，写了第一部伟大的纳尔逊传记。我的意思是，他说英国人感到的不仅仅是一场公共灾难。人们听到这个消息时大吃一惊，脸色苍白，就好像听到了挚友离世的消息一样。
to speak with emotion. And Tom, you think this is out of guilt. Well, I hope so because he snubbed Nelson, didn't he? He was not as supportive of the great man as he could have been. Yes. So, you know, as day dawns, the news spreads across London, the newspapers printed special editions, a huge crowd assembled at the Admiralty, totally silent. It's an amazing thing. You know, the Royal Navy had won the victory that had been longed for for so long. Britain was definitively safe from invasion, you know, mistress of the seas, and yet it is the loss of Nelson that is the sort of first entry in their headlines. Yeah, so Robert Southey, who becomes a poet laureate, and wrote the first great biography of Nelson. I mean, he said it was felt in England as something more than a public calamity. Men started at the intelligence and turned pale as if they had heard of the loss of a dear friend.
还有另一位诗人，塞缪尔·泰勒·柯勒律治，当时在那不勒斯。他说，人们在街上不断走过来安慰他，握着他的手时，自己也放声大哭。当然，在那不勒斯，你知道，有些人恨纳尔逊。还有一些人把他视为救世主。完全正确。所以我们将在下周为“历史俱乐部”会员准备的额外剧集中讨论爱玛和范妮以及他们后来的遭遇，对吧，汤姆？所以这算是一个加入“历史俱乐部”的动力吧，如果还需要的话。
And there's another poet, Samuel Taylor Coleridge, who was in Naples at the time. And he said that people kept coming up to him in the streets to console him and said, as they held my hand, they burst themselves into tears. Of course, Naples, you know, there are some people who hated Nelson. There were others who regarded him as their saviour. Exactly. So we'll talk about Emma and Fanny and what happened to them in next week's bonus episode for our Restis History Club members, weren't we, Tom? So that's an incentive, if any, be needed to join the Restis History Club.
但让我们简要总结一下纳尔逊本人后来发生了什么。胜利号于12月5日回到英国，船上载着纳尔逊的遗体，遗体保存在一个桶里，先是用白兰地保存，后来转移到一个装有纯酒精的桶里。圣诞节前两天，胜利号到达泰晤士河口，水手们在那里把纳尔逊的遗体移入他亲自准备的棺材中，这口棺材是用尼罗河战役中法国旗舰“东方号”（L'Orient）的主桅杆雕刻而成的。这被装上了一艘较小的船，汤姆，我知道你会很高兴得知这艘船叫“查塔姆号”（Chatham），它将顺流而上。
But let's just wrap up what happened to Nelson himself. The victory got back to Britain on the 5th of December, and it was carrying Nelson's body which had been preserved in a barrel, first with brandy and then transferred into one with pure alcohol. And two days before Christmas the victory reached the estuary of the Thames and there the sailors moved Nelson's body into the coffin that he had personally prepared carved from the mast of L'Oriand, the French flagship at the Nile. And this was loaded onto a smaller ship which Tom, I know it will delight you to know, was called the Chatham for the journey up river.
全程都有纳尔逊的私人牧师斯科特神父陪伴，他自始至终都没有离开过纳尔逊身边。平安夜那天，“查塔姆号”向西驶入泰晤士河。当它驶过时，堡垒鸣炮致敬，其他船只降半旗致哀，河畔村庄的
and it was accompanied the whole way by the Reverend Scott, Nelson's personal chaplain who hadn't left his side the whole time. And at Christmas Eve, the Chatham sailed west up the River Thames. As it passed, the forts fired their guns and the other ships lowered their flags in mourning and the bells told
钟声敲响了。平安夜下午早些时候，他们到达了格林尼治皇家医院，这里是安放遗体的完美地点。你知道，格林尼治的彩绘大厅，那是英国航海传统、君主制、英国贸易等一切事物的圣殿。纳尔逊的遗体在那里停灵，成千上万的人排着队从他的遗体旁走过。这些人正是纳尔逊为之战斗的人。因此，他们清楚地知道自己欠他多少。遗体一直在那里
in the sort of riverside villages. By early afternoon and Christmas Eve, they'd reached the Royal Hospital at Greenwich, which is the perfect place for it. You know, the painted hall at Greenwich, the kind of temple to Britain's maritime traditions and to the monarchy and to British trade and all of these things. And there Nelson kind of lay in state and thousands of people filed past his body, you know, shuffled past. These are the people for whom Nelson had fought. And so they knew exactly how much they owed him. And it remained
停放到1月8日。然后它被装上皇家驳船，前往伦敦。这其实是一个令人惊叹的奇观。由来自胜利号的少尉担任卫兵。所有护航舰船都由特拉法尔加的其他英雄指挥。所以信号中尉帕斯科已经从伤势中恢复，还有亨利·布莱克伍德、托马斯·哈迪。他们都在那里，成为这场盛大庆典的一部分。河岸上挤满了观众，礼炮轰鸣。他们最终到达伦敦，棺材最后一次被送到海军部，送到皇家海军总部，斯科特神父再次
there till the 8th of January. And then it was loaded onto the Royal Barge to make the journey into London. And it was an amazing spectacle, actually. You know, lieutenants from the victory as guards. All the escort ships were commanded by the other heroes of Trafalgar. So Pascoe, the signals lieutenant, who's recovered from his wounds, Henry Blackwood, Thomas Hardy. They're all there, kind of part of this pageantry. Great crowds of spectators on the banks, guns, firing. And eventually they got to London and the coffin was taken to the Admiralty one last time to the headquarters of the Royal Navy and again the Reverend Scott
通宵守灵。然后是星期四，1月9日，葬礼本身。我的意思是，这不仅是英国最伟大的公众奇观之一，而且它为国家英雄去世时所能期待的葬礼树立了模板，
kept vigil all night with it. And then Thursday, the 9th of January, the funeral itself and I mean it's not just one of Britain's greatest public spectacles but it establishes the template doesn't it of what a great national hero
因为它为威灵顿和丘吉尔的葬礼树立了模板，但纳尔逊是第一个。是的。我的意思是，那是一个极冷的白天，街上有成千上万的人。你知道，在那个年代，你无法真正估算人群的规模。他们看到的是一场盛大的游行，一辆巨大的黑色灵车，设计成胜利号的模样。我有点无法想象那会是什么样子。有点俗气。是的。你知道，鼓声低沉。远处有礼炮声。圣保罗大教堂的会众从早上7点就已经坐在那里了。
can expect when he dies because it establishes the template for Wellington and for Churchill in their funerals but it is Nelson who is the first Yeah. I mean, it was a freezing day, thousands upon thousands of people in the streets. You know, these are days when you can't really estimate the size of the crowd. And what they saw was this great parade, this huge black funeral carriage, which had been designed to resemble the victory. I can't quite get my head around what that would have looked like. It's a little bit vulgar. Yeah. You know, the drums are muffled. There are kind of cannon shots in the distance. The congregation at St. Paul's Cathedral had been there since 7 o'clock in the morning. taking their seats. When Nelson's coffin finally got there, a team of sailors carried the coffin to the altar, followed by a procession of Nelson's family, leading politicians, not William Pitt,
落座了。当纳尔逊的棺材终于到达时，一队水手将棺材抬到祭坛前，后面跟着纳尔逊的家属、主要政客（威廉·皮特除外，他已经重病缠身，不久于人世），但有王室的年轻成员，伦敦市的人等等。主要的哀悼者是皮特·帕克爵士（Sir Peter Parker），他是一位海军上将，曾在四分之三个世纪前在加勒比海给了纳尔逊第一个指挥权。所以非常贴切。在下午5点30分，伴随着“他的名字将永远活着”的话语，纳尔逊被缓缓降入地下室。
who's already seriously ill and is going to end up dying. But there are junior members of the royal family, people from the city of London and so on. And the chief mourner was Sir Peter Parker, who was the admiral who had given Nelson his first command in the Caribbean a quarter of a century earlier. So very fitting. A 5.30 at the words, his name liveth forever more. Nelson was lowered into the crypt
他安息在最初为沃尔西红衣主教建造或制作、后来被亨利八世拿走的石棺里。但如果你今天去圣保罗大教堂，看到的就是这个。最后一个时刻，如果纳尔逊的故事还不够戏剧化的话，
and he rests in the sarcophagus that was originally built for or made for Cardinal Woolsey and then was taken by Hemorrh of the 8th. But that's what you see if you go to St. Paul's today. And the last moment, I mean, if Nelson's story couldn't be any more theatrical,
最后，水手们本应取下胜利号的旗帜并将其折叠起来放入墓穴中。但相反，水手们在所有人面前把它撕成了碎片，每个人都为自己留下一片碎片，作为小小的纪念，也象征着纳尔逊一生属于皇家海军，现在他永远属于他们了。这就是纳尔逊入土为安。
at the end, the sailors were meant to take the victory's flag. and fold it and to lay it in the grave. But instead, what the sailors did was they ripped it up in front to everybody, and each man took a fragment for himself, like a little reminder, and a sort of sense that Nelson who belonged to the Royal Navy all his life, now he was theirs forever. So that is Nelson laid in his grave.
我们大概应该回顾一下本集及整个故事中出现的其他一些角色。所以科林伍德于1810年在海上去世。“蹦跳”（Bounce，纳尔逊的狗）在特拉法尔加战役中幸存下来，我很高兴地说。托马斯·哈迪，他成为了一名从男爵。他成为了第一海军大臣。他于1839年去世，人们永远记得他的那一吻。可怜的维尔讷夫，他作为囚犯被带回去了，对吧？
We should probably just go through some of the other characters who featured in this episode and the story more generally. So Collingwood, he dies at sea in 1810. Bounce had survived the Battle of Trafalgar, I'm glad to say. Thomas Hardy, he became a baronet. He became a first naval lord. He died in 1839, always remembered for his kiss. Poor old Villeneuve, he's brought back as a prisoner, isn't he?
他最后住在汉普郡的一家酒馆里。我喜欢汉普郡的酒馆，所以我想象不出比这更糟的归宿了。他实际上去了纳尔逊的葬礼，然后设法回到了法国，接着于1806年在雷恩被发现死亡，也就是特拉法尔加战役一年后。
He ends up in a pub in Hampshire. I love a pub in Hampshire, so I can think of worse vates. he actually goes to Nelson's funeral and then he managed to get back to France and he's then found dead in Rann in 1806 so a year after Trafalgar
这是一个巨大的谜团，因为不清楚他是自杀身亡还是被谋杀。有些人说他是出于内疚、失望、抑郁等原因自杀的；但在英国，尤其是因为人们愿意把拿破仑想象得最坏，
and it's a great mystery because it's unclear whether he committed suicide or whether he'd actually been murdered so some people said he committed suicide out of guilt or disappointment or depression or whatever but in Britain in particular because people wanted to believe the worst of Napoleon
人们普遍认为他是被拿破仑的特工谋杀的，作为输掉特拉法尔加战役的惩罚。听起来这正是科西嘉人会做的事，你觉得呢，汤姆？我的意思是，英国和法国情报机构之间一直存在着一场令人难以置信的隐秘情报战，充满了“锅匠、裁缝、士兵、间谍”式的偏旁妄想。所以你可以看到这些故事是如何出现的。绝对是这样。关于纳尔逊的故事总是有一个伟大之处，那就是总会有另一个戏剧性的高潮出现。这是我最喜欢的之一。西班牙海军上将格拉维纳（Admiral Gravina）在特拉法尔加战役中受伤。
It was widely believed that he'd been murdered by Napoleon's agents as punishment for losing the Bethel of Republic. It sounds like exactly the kind of thing that Corsican would do, don't you think, Tom? I mean, there has all along in the background been this incredible intelligence war raging between the British and French intelligence services, kind of Tinker Taylor's soldier spy paranoia. So you can see how those stories would emerge. Definitely. And then there's always a great thing about the story of Nelson is there's always yet another melodramatic flourish to come. And this is one of my favorites. So Admiral Gravina, the Spanish Admiral, who'd been wounded at Trafalgar.
他从未康复，也于1806年去世。他在西班牙的临终病榻上，受到了一位英国医生的探视，据报道格拉维纳的遗言是：“我死而无憾。我要去了。我希望并相信能加入纳尔逊的行列，他也许是世界上产生过的最伟大的英雄。”多米尼克，顺便说一句，这完全取决于一位英国医生的证词。但我认为所有听众都会同意，这
He never recovered, and he also died in 1806. And on his deathbed in Spain, he was visited by a British doctor who reported that Gravina's last words were, I die happy. I am going. I hope and trust to join Nelson, perhaps the greatest hero that the world has produced. And Dominic, just to be clear, this depends entirely on the testimony of a British, doctor. But I think everybody listened to this would agree that this
绝对、非常清楚地会发生。毫无疑问，这就是格拉维纳最后的遗言。所以多米尼克，还有两个人。是的，纳尔逊勋爵夫人范妮，你对她很有好感。所以她从政府得到了一笔年金。她得到了纳尔逊应得的奖金。
definitely, this really clearly would have happened. There's no doubt that that would have been Gravina's final sentiment. So Dominant, two more people. Yeah. Fanny, Lady Nelson, who you have a great tondress for. So she gets a pension from the government. She gets the money that Nelson is owed
这笔钱也归她所有。她在1815年滑铁卢战役后来到巴黎，呆在那里，然后隐居到埃克斯茅斯。在她生命的最后几年里，她一直保持着她一贯的尊严的化身。她与纳尔逊的军官们关系良好。她修复了与他家人的关系。威廉四世，也就是之前的克拉伦斯公爵，纳尔逊的老朋友，来看望过她，她于1831年去世。所以她有着，你知道，不能算是不幸的后纳尔逊生活。
from all the prizes. That goes to her as well. She goes to Paris after 1815 and Waterloo stays there and then she retires to Exmouth, and throughout her final years, she remains what she has always been, the absolute soul of respectability. She's on good terms with Nelson's officers. She rebuilds bridges with his family. And William IV, Duke of Clarence, as had been, kind of old mucker of Nelson's, he comes and visits her, and she dies in 1831. So she has, you know, haven't called it a happy post-Nelson life
从所有的战利品中分得一份。这本来也是属于她的。1815年滑铁卢战役之后她去了巴黎并留在那儿，接着她退隐到埃克斯茅斯。在她生命的最后几年里，她依然保持着她一直以来的样子，绝对是体面和尊重的化身。她与纳尔逊的军官们保持着良好的关系。她修复了与他家人的关系。曾任克拉伦斯公爵的威廉四世，也就是纳尔逊的老朋友，曾来探望过她，她于1831年去世。所以她拥有了，你知道的，虽然不能完全说是幸福的纳尔逊之后的生活
but a comfortable a comfortable and prosperous one whether that is what Emma Hamilton has we will find out as we've been saying in the bonus that is out next week and also the fate of Horatia Nelson's daughter
但这是一个舒适且富裕的结局，艾玛·汉密尔顿是否得到了这样的结局，我们将在下周播出的特别节目中揭晓，同时还将探讨霍雷夏·纳尔逊女儿的命运
who was so much on his mind as he lay dying on victory so Nelson after his death as Andrew Lambert the historian puts it he was transformed from a living hero into a national god. And part of this, I think, is about the context. So actually, while Nelson has been laid to rest and people have been mourning, Napoleon
他在“胜利”号上垂死时，这个名字是如此深刻地印在他的脑海中。因此，正如历史学家安德鲁·兰伯特所说，纳尔逊死后，他从一个活着的英雄变成了一位民族神祇。我认为，部分原因在于当时的背景。事实上，正当纳尔逊入土为安、人们在哀悼时，拿破仑
has won the Battle of Austerlitz. So Napoleon has been absolutely smiting, you know, the Austrians and the Prussians and whatnot. It's clear this is going to be a very long war, and Britain needs a martyred naval hero. So Nelson is turned into a kind of 19th century classical hero, isn't he? as you were saying, the kind of Christian Achilles, he's immortalized in stone, in classical style. The first monument was actually commissioned in Hereford. Nelson was a kind of freemen of the city of Hereford or something, and the people of Hereford were keen to celebrate this. Then there was an obelisk in Portsmouth.
赢得了奥斯特里茨战役。拿破仑可谓彻底击溃了奥地利人、普鲁士人等等。很明显，这将是一场非常漫长的战争，而英国需要一个殉国的海军英雄。于是，纳尔逊被塑造成了一种19世纪的古典英雄，不是吗？正如你所说，他就像一位基督化身的阿喀琉斯，以古典风格被永垂不朽地雕刻在石头上。第一个纪念碑实际上是在赫里福德订购的。纳尔逊曾是赫里福德城的荣誉市民之类的人物，赫里福德的人民热切地希望赞美他。接着，朴茨茅斯也建立了一座方尖碑。
There was the famous pillar in Dublin, which was blown up in the 1960s. And then there were Birmingham, Glasgow, Liverpool. Not just in Britain, actually. So Montreal, there's a column. There's a column in Barbados. the city of Nelson, New Zealand is named after Nelson, the island of Nelson, British Columbia, in Canada. And most famously, later, Trafalgar Square.
都柏林曾有著名的纳尔逊之柱，但在20世纪60年代被炸毁了。随后，伯明翰、格拉斯哥和利物浦也建起了纪念碑。其实不仅在英国，比如蒙特利尔有一根圆柱，巴巴多斯也有一根。新西兰的纳尔逊市是以纳尔逊的名字命名的，加拿大不列颠哥伦比亚省的纳尔逊岛也是如此。最著名的，当然要数后来的特拉法加广场。
So you're the expert on the architecture of London, Tom. What's the story here? Yeah, and of course Nelson's column. And neither of these were built until the 1840s. And essentially the problem with building Trafalgar Square is that they had to get rid of a lot of slums and rackety old buildings. And actually among the buildings that ends up being cleared was the tavern where coaches from Chester would arrive and unload their human cargo. And one of those people who would have stepped out of the coach from Chester into this tavern would have been the very, very young girl who would go on to become Emma Hamilton.
所以你是伦敦建筑方面的专家，汤姆。这里面有什么故事？是的，当然还有纳尔逊纪念柱。这两者直到19世纪40年代才建造。建造特拉法加广场的根本问题在于，他们必须清除大量的贫民窟和破旧的建筑。事实上，最终被拆除的建筑中，就包括了一家客栈，从切斯特来的马车曾经会在那里抵达并卸下乘客。而从切斯特的马车上下来、走进这家客栈的某个人，正是那个后来成为艾玛·汉密尔顿的极其年轻的女孩。
And so obviously the centrepiece of Trafalgar Square is this great column, both in its design and the proportions. of the column from a column that's pretty much all that survives of the Temple of Mars Altar in Rome that was built by Augustus. And on its base, it has four reliefs illustrating the four great victories won by Nelson or in which he assisted. So Capes in Vincent, the Nile, Copenhagen and Trafalgar. And the relief of Trafalgar is the one that has the black sailor, probably a young man called George Ryan, who was age 23 when he took part in Trafalgar.
很显然，特拉法加广场的核心就是这根巨大的圆柱，无论是它的设计还是比例。这根圆柱的比例源自罗马奥古斯都建造的战神玛尔斯神庙中几乎仅存的圆柱。在它的基座上，有四个浮雕，描绘了纳尔逊赢得或协助赢下的四场伟大胜利：圣文生角、尼罗河、哥本哈根和特拉法加。特拉法加的浮雕上有一个黑人水手，很可能是一个名叫乔治·赖恩的年轻人在参加特拉法加战役时年仅23岁。
And I guess it's the ultimate architectural symbol of British patriotism, isn't it? I mean, that's certainly what Hitler thought, because his plan was when he conquered Britain, that he would remove Nelson's column and take it to Berlin. Yes, I think for the next 150 years or so, Nelson was the supreme icon, wasn't he, the great patriotic icon, celebrated in paintings and poetry. by great historians. Yeah, but also I think an inspiration to future Britons who might dream of serving and saving their country,
我想这是英国爱国主义的终极建筑象征，对吧？我的意思是，希特勒显然也是这么想的，因为他的计划是在征服英国后，把纳尔逊纪念柱拆掉并运到柏林。是的，我认为在接下来的大约150年里，纳尔逊一直是至高无上的偶像，不是吗？那个伟大的爱国偶像，在绘画、诗歌以及伟大历史学家的著作中受到赞美。是的，但我也认为他激励了未来那些梦想为国效力、拯救国家的英国人，
of whom obviously there's one in particular because Churchill was obsessed by Nelson. He had a bust of Nelson at Chartwell. When he was at the Admiralty, he called the Cat There Nelson. And in 1945, he belonged to this dining club. So Keynes was in it, Lloyd George. H.G. Wells, Lutchins, the great architect. And they got together and pulled their donations to try and buy him Nelson's gold snuffbox,
其中显然有一个特别的人，因为丘吉尔对纳尔逊痴迷不已。他在查特韦尔庄园里摆放了一尊纳尔逊的半身像。当他在海军部任职时，他把那只猫叫做“纳尔逊”。1945年，他加入了这个餐饮俱乐部，凯恩斯、劳埃德·乔治、H·G·威尔斯、伟大建筑师鲁琴斯都是会员。他们聚在一起凑钱，试图为他买下纳尔逊的金鼻烟壶，
which had come up for auction. That's nice. I love that story. Now, in the last 10 or 20 years or so, there have been some very sort of half-hearted attempts to kind of cancel Nelson because of his opposition to abolitionism, you know, because he's associated with the Royal Navy and Empire and so on. Not that he was, I mean, he's more associated with fighting the front. He's not conquering other peoples. But they have never really succeeded.
这个鼻烟壶当时正拿出来拍卖。太棒了。我喜欢这个故事。现在，在过去的10到20年里，有一些非常敷衍的尝试，想要因为纳尔逊反对废奴主义而取消他，你知道的，因为他与皇家海军和帝国联系在一起等等。尽管他其实——我的意思是，他更多地与前线作战联系在一起，他并不是在征服其他民族。但这些尝试从未真正成功过。
And actually, I think Nelson remains, you know, he's definitely in the top five of sort of Britons in the public imagination, don't you think? I mean, when you look at the stats, so HMS victory at Portsmouth, there are more than 30 million people have gone to HMS victory in the last century. So that's about a third of a million people every year go and kind of walk the deck and everybody, you know, has their photo taken by the spot where there's the little plaque, isn't there, on the deck. This is where Nelson fell. You know, all of that. Nelson's victory at Trafalgar particularly does facilitate Britain's command of the oceans, which in turn facilitates the growth of the British Empire in the 19th century. But it does also, as we've said, facilitate the Royal Navy's campaign against the slave trade. I think that that makes him a less controversial imperial hero than almost any other. As you say, he's chiefly known for defeating the French, and I think that that remains. A brilliant thing. Well, it remains a kind of thing for which a British hero is unlikely to be cancelled.
事实上，我认为纳尔逊依然——你知道的，他绝对排在公众心目中最伟大的英国人前五名，你不觉得吗？如果你看看统计数据，朴茨茅斯“胜利”号战舰的数据显示，在上个世纪，有超过3000万人参观了“胜利”号。这意味着每年大约有三十万人去那里在甲板上走一走，每个人都会在甲板上那个有小牌匾的地方拍照留念，不是吗？这就是纳尔逊倒下的地方。你知道，诸如此类。纳尔逊在特拉法加的胜利确实极大地促进了英国对海洋的掌控，这反过来又促进了19世纪大英帝国的扩张。但正如我们所说，这也促进了皇家海军打击奴隶贸易的行动。我认为这使他成为一个比几乎任何其他人物都争议更小的帝国英雄。正如你所说，他主要因击败法国人而闻名，我认为这一点依然存在。这是一件了不起的事。嗯，它仍然是英国英雄不太可能被“取消”的那类事情。
Yeah, I think so. Of course, the great thing about Nelson is he embodies something bigger than himself, the Navy, which was then the most modern organisation in the world. the sinews of of industrial power I see in the chat Theo's muttering about Naples but I think we can
是的，我也这么认为。当然，纳尔逊最伟大之处在于他体现了比他自身更宏大的事物——海军，那是当时世界上最现代化的组织，是工业力量的骨干。我看到聊天区里西奥在嘟囔着那不勒斯的事，但我想我们可以
in this episode of all episodes we can just completely ignore whatever Theo is saying because of course what he resisted was Bonaparte's tyranny don't you think
在所有这些集的节目中，我们可以完全忽略西奥在说什么，因为很显然，他所抵抗的是波拿巴的暴政，你不觉得吗？
and actually do you know what don't take it from me take it from no lesser person than the President of the United States who when he came to Windsor Castle said in his speech to King Charles. The lion-hearted people of this kingdom defeated Napoleon, unleashed the Industrial Revolution, destroyed slavery and defended civilization. And you know who he's talking
而且，你知道吗，不要听我怎么说，去听听美国总统是怎么说的，他来到温莎城堡时在对查尔斯国王的演讲中说道：这个王国坚韧不拔的人民击败了拿破仑，引发了工业革命，摧毁了奴隶制并捍卫了文明。你知道他在说
about? He's talking about Nelson. He is. Yeah. But I mean, I suppose also the other reason why Nelson endures in the public imagination and retains his popularity is precisely that he is a kind of hero of flesh and blood and that he does make mistakes and he does behave ludicrously. And there is a kind of comic element to him. And that also, I think, is a part of what makes him so appeal. I mean, makes him, I think, more appealing than, say, the Duke of Wellington, who's a much more granite figure. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. It's the fact that he is, he's a human being, you know, and it's not just the sometimes ludicrous vanity and the love life and stuff, but it's the sheer physical courage in putting himself at the front. It's the
谁吗？他说的是纳尔逊。确实如此。是的。但我的意思是，我想纳尔逊在公众想象中得以长存并保持受欢迎的另一个原因，恰恰在于他是一个有血有肉的英雄，他会犯错，也会做出荒谬的举动。他身上有一种喜剧色彩。而且我认为，这也是他如此具有吸引力的一部分原因。我的意思是，这让他比那些更像花岗岩雕像般冷酷的人物——比如威灵顿公爵——更具吸引力。是的，完全正确。完全正确。事实就是他是一个活生生的人，你知道的，这不仅仅是那些有时显得荒谬的虚荣心、风流韵事之类的东西，而是他冲锋陷阵时的纯粹体能勇气。这是
the leadership, you know, the camaraderie, the warmth with which he related to his men and his men to him. And I think, you know, we always pair him with Napoleon. And they do have things in common, this kind of insatiable thirst for fame and for glory. But I think the big, for me, the big difference between these two characters is Napoleon is only ever interested in Napoleon. But Nelson, it's about the institution. It's about, you know, service and duty. And those are not really words, you know, it's la gloa that means most to Napoleon. But I think what means most to Nelson is this sense of institutional responsibility. And, you know, you've quoted many times, Collingwood saying of Nelson, you know, he was a brilliant warrior, but he had no
领导力，你知道的，那种袍泽之情，他与部下之间以及部下与他之间的融洽与温暖。而且我认为，你知道的，我们总是把他和拿破仑相提并论。他们确实有共同点，比如对名誉和荣耀有着这种无法餍足的渴望。但对我来说，这两个人物之间最大的区别在于，拿破仑关心的永远只有拿破仑自己。而纳尔逊，一切都是为了机构。一切都是为了，你知道的，服务与职责。这些其实并不是空话，你知道的，对拿破仑来说意义最大的是“无上光荣”（la gloire）。但我认为对纳尔逊来说意义最大的是这种机构责任感。而且，你知道的，你多次引用柯林伍德对纳尔逊的评价，你知道他是一个杰出的战士，但他并没有
foolish passion for fighting. He was the most gentle of human creatures. Collingwood said what made him fight was his love of Britain, her laws and liberty. And that for me is why his last words on the victory are such a perfect epitaph, God and my country. And on that patriotic note, thank you everyone for listening. Thank you, Dominic. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对战斗的愚蠢狂热。他是最温和的人类。柯林伍德说，让他去战斗的是他对英国、对她的法律和自由的热爱。对我来说，这就是为什么他在“胜利”号上的遗言堪称最完美的墓志铭：上帝与我的国家。带着这份爱国情怀，感谢大家的收听。谢谢你，多米尼克。再见。拜拜。谢谢。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。